THERE WE GO. YEAH HEY SHE THAT
GOOD KARMA ALL RIGHT THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL
COME TO ORDER IN SIXTY SECONDS.
TO SOMEBODY TELL ME ONE MORE
LIVE. WE'RE LIVE ALRIGHT SO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS FROM
THE ORDER. THE MORNING AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MAN OUR MANAGER
ON GOING COVE IN NINETEEN REST
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC IN ITS PROVIDED
ACCESS BOTH IN PERSON AND
THROUGH THE TOP OFFENSE. LINE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR RISK THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE. IT WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
OBVIOUSLY I'LL ANNOUNCE IT RIGHT
NOW THE PARTICIPANT NUMBERS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX.
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE AGAIN. EIGHT
SEVEN. EIGHT ONE SIX THREE THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO.
TWO FOUR SIX TWO AGAIN ACCESS
CODE. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO OBVIOUSLY ALL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE OCHE REBUILDING
AND OBVIOUSLY WE WANT AS MANY
MEMBERS HERE'S POSSIBLE WE'VE
GOT FOR. THE WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING. MR SECRETARY MR
CONSULTING WOULD YOU PUT WELL I
MEAN THAT'S A KEEPER AND WE HAVE
A HUNDRED BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA ONE OF WHICH IS A DO PASS
THE REST ARE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS INFORMED US THAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE FILES FOR ANY
OF THE BILLS WERE HEARING AND A
REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING. FOR ANYONE
LISTENING WHO IS INTERESTED IN
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR
WIENER. THAT BILL IS STILL
LISTED ON THE DAILY FILE BUT IT
HAS BEEN RESCHEDULED FOR OUR
HEARING OF MAY SIXTEENTH WILL BE
HERE. FOR SB. ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX
WE WILL NOT BE DEALING WITH THAT
TODAY. SO RIGHT NOW WILL
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM SO MISTER
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PORTANTINO I'M HERE
SINCE PORTANTINO HERE SENATOR
BATES. SENATOR BRADFORD. CENTER
JONES. CENTER KAMLAGER HERE
CENTER KAMLAGER HERE SENATOR
LAYERED HERE CENTER LAYERED HERE
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI HERE
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI HERE WE
HAVE FOUR MEMBERS PRESENT YOU
HAVE BRADFORD OF ME SAID HERE
THE NEW BRADFORD HERE ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE CENTER BRADFORD. HE'S
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
BUSINESS DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARING
AND TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. I'M
RESERVING THE RIGHT TO INSTITUTE
A TIME LIMIT ON WITNESS
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES OF TOTAL
TIME FOR PRIMARY TESTIMONY. ALL
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURE IF NECESSARY WILL
ALSO LIMIT. ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE
AS A REMINDER ALL WITNESSES
SHOULD LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL
THIS IS A PHYSICAL COMMITTEE NOT
A POLICY COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO RE LITIGATE. THE POLICY
MERITS OF A BILL WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON THE FISCAL ASPECTS SO
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM ANY PRIOR
TESTIMONY RELATED TO. POLICY
OMINOUS STRICTLY APPLIED TO ME
TOO A NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION- PERSPECTIVE SO PLEASE
KEEP THAT IN MIND. SO THE NEXT
ITEM WE'RE GONNA GO RIGHT TO OUR
ORDER OF BUSINESS WHICH IS OUR
FIRST ITEM IS SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR. BY SENATOR WIENER'S
WHICH IS ON TAX EXEMPT STATUS
INSURRECTION. AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO THAT- TESTIMONY WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOR ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM WISHING
TO SUPPORT. SB EIGHT THIRTY
FOUR. NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WE BOTH. SUPPORT POSTS YES
THEY WERE IN SUPPORT. OF A OKAY
YEAH SO MODERATOR IF ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE IS IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT THREE FOUR NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY. TO SUPPORT SB EIGHT
THREE FOUR. AND TO DO SO PLEASE
ONE ZERO AGAIN TO SUPPORT SB
EIGHT THREE FOUR THREE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BIRKELAND.
TWENTY SEVEN. TWENTY SEVEN YEAR
OPEN. I WILL GO TO LIVE FIFTY
SIX IF I HAD. YEAH NOT I'M GOING
TO UP OKAY. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOT ON THAT
BILL RIGHT NOW. WE'LL GO TO.
LIFE. FIFTY NINE. WE WE'RE
CALLING TO OPPOSE THE SENATOR
PAN BILL. POLITICIAN BUT WE'RE
NOT ON THAT BUILT SO MODERATOR
AND FOLKS LISTENING AT HOME. WE
TAKE THE BILLS IN BILL ORDER-
AND BY AUTHOR SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE
ON S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FOUR SO WE
ONLY WANT SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR YOU'RE HERE FOR
OTHER BILLS JUST WAIT YOUR TURN.
AND PRESS YOUR NUMBER WHEN WE DO
THOSE BILLS SO PLEASE PAY
ATTENTION AND WE'LL GET ALL
THROUGH THIS SMOOTHLY SO RUN SB
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR MODERATORS OR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR. IT CURRENTLY NO NO
OTHERS AND ON ALL RIGHT NOW WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION EIGHT
THREE FOUR WE'RE GONNA COME BACK
TO ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED YARDS
YOU'RE NOT LISTED AS A PRIMARY.
WITNESS BUT COME ON HOW CUTE YOU
COME COME BACK BUT YOU. JUST
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION MY NAME IS TOM I'M A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
CARMICHAEL AND I OPPOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
THIS ROOM. OPPOSED SB EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR. YES HI MY NAME IS
SERENA LODGING REPRESENTATIVES
WHO PROBABLY RUNNING FOR US
SENATE. IN WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB EIGHT THREE FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. JULIA
STILES- TODAY WAS RELEASED ON
YOU TUBE AYE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
THREE FOUR THANK YOU. THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS SARAH I AM- FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA AND I OPPOSE BILL BUT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. JUST GO
AFTER STOCKTON CALIFORNIA OPPOSE. HI JAMES JAMES FRY SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA- I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING RESPECTFUL EACH SPACE SYSTEM NO ONE ELSE
IN THIS ROOM SO MODERATOR PLEASE
GO TO THE PHONE LINE WE'RE DOING
OPPOSITION TO S. B. EIGHT THREE
FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE SB
EIGHT THREE FOR YOU TO ONE OF
CRAFT. ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
THAT'S PROPOSITIONS SB EIGHT
THIRTY FOR. THE FIRST CAROLINE
EIGHTEEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GABRIELLE INGRAHAM FOUNDER OF
STAND AT SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
WE DO NOT SUPPORT THAT STILL.
PHOTO NEXT TO LINE FIFTY NINE.
FOLLOWING YOUR OWN PROCESS
UNIQUE HAVE A WITNESS IN THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT PERSON NEXT NEXUS NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JEANETTE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU. LET'S CHECK OUT LINE FORTY
SEVEN. MY MOTHER TAUGHT ME TO BE
POLITE. FIVE HI KATHLEEN PONAD-
KERN COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. WE GET WE HAVE
ONE MORE HERE WILL GO LINE.
ELEVEN HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME
IS LAURIE ENOUGH FROM KERN ON MY
COUNTY CALIFORNIA. REPRESENTING
SAVE ARSENAL NINE OF THE CELL.
AND CURRENTLY NOT FURTHER YOU Q.
ALL RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKING
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR WILL GO TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE I SHOULD HAVE SAID
IN THE BEGINNING THE AUTHOR WAY
PRESENTATION AND IT WAS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
GOES TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB
EIGHT FIFTY THREE ALSO BY
SENATOR WIENER ON PRESCRIPTION
DRUG COVERAGE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVE
PRESENTATION SO WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT FIFTY THREE WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT SB EIGHT FIFTY
THREE COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
THERE'S NOBODY COMING UP TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIFTY THREE. FOUR SB EIGHT
FIFTY THREE AGAIN PRESS ONE
ZERO. FIRST ALLIED FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE WAITER IS
DEALING WITH. THREE Q. SO FOR
FOLKS WE ARE ON SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIFTY THREE WE'RE ASKING
FOR YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
AND CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL
RIGHT NOW WE WILL COME BACK TO
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FIFTY
THREE IF YOU'RE HERE TO OPPOSE
SB EIGHT FIFTY THREE. THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY THERE'S NOBODY
COMING TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE IF THERE'S ANYONE OPPOSED
SB EIGHT FIFTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
OPPOSE SB EIGHT FIFTY THREE.
CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND SEEING THEIR QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FIFTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE LIVING ON SB NINE SIXTY
FOUR FROM SENATOR WIENER ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THIS IS ALSO
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS ROOM
FOR SUPPORT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
COME TO THE MICROPHONE IN
SUPPORT MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SIXTY FOUR. FOR SB NINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S. ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WILL NOT GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
THERE'S ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO NINE SIXTY FOUR COME
UP TO THE MICROPHONE NOBODY'S
COMING UP TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB NINE SIX FOUR. THE POST SB
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THERE AT THIS TIME. FIRST WE'LL
GO TO LINE ELEVEN. IF I HAD.
NINE EIGHT ZERO. BY ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- MAYBE UNTIL NINE
ELEVEN HEAR ME WE CAN- OKAY ONE
NUMBER FOR ALL THE BILLS I'M I'M
CALLING ABOUT. DOCTOR NO ONE CAN
YOU POST SB. NINE FIFTY FOUR BY
FOUR. THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE.
FIFTY SEVEN. I THINK THE NEXT
MEMBER OF STAND UP SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WITH OF THIS BILL YEAH.
TO A LINE FIFTY NINE. WE HAVE
EVERYTHING ABOUT SENATOR WINNER
INCLUDING THE MODEL THANK YOU.
IN OCTOBER TO LYING SIXTY FIVE.
THEREFORE SIXTY FIVE MILLION.
YOUR AVAILABLE TO. AT SIXTY FIVE
I WOULD LIKE TO LIVE. FIFTY SIX.
MY NAME. LASSEN COUNTY AND I
HAVE. ECHO ALIGN. SIXTY SIX. YES
I AM TOO FROM SANTA ROSA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND THEN FOR
THE ADDRESS ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN THE SUPPORT OPPOSITION BUT
WE HAVE ONE SUPPORTER WHO WANTS
TO COME UP AND DO A QUICK ME TOO
ON SB NINE SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU
TERM MEMBERS MATTHEW GALLAGHER
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE'VE
TAKEN A SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
SB NINE EIGHTY BY SENATOR WIENER
ON ALCOHOL BEVERAGE LICENSES.
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT
TO THE PUBLIC HEARING IN SUPPORT
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
NINE EIGHTY NOW IS YOUR TIME. NO
ONE IS COMING TO THE MICROPHONES
SO MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF NINE
EIGHTY. SB NINE EIGHTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIRECTOR OF TIME. WE
CAN GO CLIMB FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE FIFTEEN YOU'RE OPEN-
EIGHT MISTER MEMBERS PAUL EUROPE
HAVE THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF IT SB
NINETY THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE.
SIXTY ONE. STOPPER SANTA MONICA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SUPPORT. NO
FURTHER WEST THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WILL NOT GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE EIGHTY IF
YOU'RE IN THIS ROOM IN YOUR
OPPOSED SB NINE EIGHTY THIS IS
YOUR TIME TO COME FORWARD TO
SEEING NOBODY RUSH TO THE
MICROPHONES THE MODERATOR WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE OF
OPPOSITION SB NINE EIGHTY PLEASE
QUEUE UP. AND PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO OPPOSE. WHAT A LIFE
FIFTY SEVENTY FOUR HAD. FIVE
FIFTY SEVEN. WELL SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THE BILL.
MMHM. IT CURRENTLY NOT FURTHER
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION S. B. NINE AC
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE EIGHTY
GOES TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
ONE ONE FOUR FOUR BY SENATOR
WIENER ON WATER EFFICIENCY AND
QUALITY ASSESSMENT REPORTS THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL GO TO
SUPPORT TESTIMONY NOW. PLEASE
COME ON UP. FORTY SENATORS MIKE
MADIGAN BEHALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY
OTHER SUPPORT THE NOT IN THIS
ROOM MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR. TO SUPPORT SB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR EIGHT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
. THANK YOU CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT
WILL NOT COME BACK TO OPPOSITION
OF ELEVEN FORTY FOUR FOR YOUR
POST ELEVEN FORTY FOUR THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY PLEASE COME ON
UP. NO ONE RUSSIAN IN THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION OF
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSE AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY SEVEN.
THE LINE FIFTY SIX MMHM
DEMOCRATIC COUNTY MY NAME'S
BRANDON I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BAKER LIMA FURTHER QUEUE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN FORTY FOUR
AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AS MENTIONED SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX HAS BEEN PUT OVER TO
THE NEXT MEETING. SO WE'LL GO ON
TO S. B. TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER ON CREDIBLE
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE DNA SAMPLES
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS
ROOM SAYING NO SUPPORT RUSHING
TO THE MICROPHONE WILL GO TO
THE- PHONE LINE MODERATE PLEASE
KEEP ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT. TO SUPPORT
SB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. I GET IT'S ONE
ZERO JUST A MOMENT HERE WITH YOU
HERE.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN. SIXTY SEVEN YEAR OPENS.
LINE SIXTY SEVEN. AND CURRENTLY
NONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
BACK TO THIS ROOM FOR OPPOSITION
OF S. B. TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY. I SEE
ONE PERSON COMING UP TO THE
MICROPHONE COME ON UP TELL US
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION
CHALLENGE PROSECUTING. STRONG
SUPPORTER- START STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SEE NO ONE ELSE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
OPPOSITION. TO TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE AT
THIS TIME FOR SINGLE LINE SIXTY
SEVEN. YOU KNOW WHAT OPPOSITION
WE OPPOSE WHY ARE YOU NOT
LETTING THE PEOPLE FEET- YOU
MODERATOR I. FEEL LIKE FIFTY
SEVEN WE ARE LETTING ANYONE ELSE
. GO AHEAD THANK YOU CAN I HELP
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. IN LINE SEVENTY
FOUR YEAR OLD. RENDON PANNED OUT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK. LINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NO
I'M NOT LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE
AND YOUR MODERATOR. HE TURNS
THANK YOU VERY GOOD. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
TO SENATOR DODD JUST BE EIGHT
FORTY TWO ON HEALTHCARE MEDICAL
GOOD SYNTHESIS SPENCE CANDIDATE
THE SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION.
WE WILL OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SEE IF ANYBODY WANTS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT FORTY TWO
THERE'S NOBODY HERE LOTTERY
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO
TAKE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT FORTY TWO. THANKS FOR SB
EIGHT FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IT'S
ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT. CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION EIGHT FORTY
TUNES ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED A FORTY TWO. SEEING NO
ONE BOTHERING TO LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION EIGHT
FORTY TWO. AND JUST A TO A
OPPOSED. SB EIGHT FORTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT REMEMBER
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATES YOU KNOW
QUESTIONS. OR COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT FORTY TWO
WILL BE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE WILL MOVE ON TO SENATOR
SKINNER HAS. S. B. EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR HOPE OPPORTUNITY
PERSEVERANCE AND EMPOWERMENT FOR
CHILDREN ACT. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT THERE
AND NOBODY COMING TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
BY SENATOR SKINNER. TO SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- NO THIS IS THE
WRONG THE WRONG- ALL RIGHT GET
BACK IN A LOT. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING MR CHAN
NUMBER IN THE COLD WARMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. IN THE
TOTAL LINE FORTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BURKE SOME
OF THEM ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SB. EIGHT FIFTY FOUR. AND THEN
FURTHER ARGUE AT THE FIVE RIGHT
WILL NOW COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED SB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR. SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR. IN TWO. THOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WHAT A LINE.
SEVENTY ONE. HELLO I AM FLORIAN
POLIS SUPPORT OF BUT AT THE
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR- CABIN OFTEN ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
BACK TO OPPOSITION. INTERPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FIFTY
FORCING OF QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB NINE NINE
THREE BY SENATOR SKINNER VICTIMS
AND PERSONS ARONIE ASLI
CONVICTED IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED SEEING NO ONE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE. FOR
SUPPORT SB NINE NINE THREE.
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT SB
NINE NINE THREE. AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT PRESS. ONE THEY'RE ALL
GOING ONLINE. SEVENTY EIGHT.
SEVENTY EIGHT EUROPEN. YES I
WELL I AM FROM COUNTY THANK YOU
. NUMBER THIRTY TWO AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF NINE NINE THREE
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
NINE NINE THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING SB TEN TEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER ON AIR POLLUTION
STATE VEHICLE FLEET IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SAYING NO ONE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF
SB TEN TEN. FOR S. P. TEN TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CLEANING
KIT. RIGHT RIGHT OPPOSITION OF
SB TEN TEN SEEING NOBODY COME TO
THE MICROPHONE IN THIS ROOM
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE OF ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB TEN
TEN. SO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
OPPOSE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF TEN TEN AND SAYING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN TEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORED
A PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME THE SUPPORT.
WE JUST MONITOR THAT ONE WITH AN
OPERATOR.
AND THE LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING THIS
IS MERION ASHLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN SUPPORT OF
SB. EIGHT SIXTY. CURRENTLY NOTED
FURTHER IF YOU RIGHT WILL NOT GO
TO OPPOSITION AT EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSE STATE SIXTY EIGHT
SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE ANYONE OPPOSED TO S. B.
EIGHT SIX EIGHT. NOW IS YOUR
TIME. FOR THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TWELVE HOLES SB EIGHT
SIX EIGHT AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT SIX EIGHT
AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE BILLION SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR CORTESE
THIS IS ON HOMELESS PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SUCCESS OPPORTUNITY
IN ACADEMIC RESILIENCE.
GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAM IT IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY HERE TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED C. NOBODY COME TO
THE MICROPHONE MODERATE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR SB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
HERE. WE CAN OPEN LINE EIGHTY
THREE. I'M OPPOSED. I THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
BACK TO OPPOSITION OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM COME INTO
THE MIKE FROM MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
OPPOSE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF THIRTEEN FORTY ONE AND
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO SENATOR
MCGUIRE HAS S. B. EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR ON ELECTRICITY EXPEDITED
UTILITY DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR CENTERS
MIKE MULLIGAN BEHALF OF BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE
ELSE RUSHED TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR. EXPRESSED WONDER AT
THIS TIME TO SUPPORT SB EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WILL
NOT GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT
EIGHT FOURS OR ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED EIGHT EIGHT FORCING
NO ONE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR. WE GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR OPPOSITION TO EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR. AND TO OPPOSE SB
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR YOU'LL WANT TO
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
GUESS ONE ZERO. IN A MOMENT HERE. YOU CAN GO TO LINE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
LEGALLY NOT NOT THIS WITH
BENDIGO GAS AND ELECTRIC IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MEXICO
LINE. EIGHTY THREE. AFTER PARTY
OPPOSE. AND FOR THEIR QUEUE AT
THIS TIME I WOULD SAY IT'S
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
EIGHT FORCING NO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR GOES TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
ON DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING AND RECOVERY WILDFIRE
DEBRIS CLEANUP AND REMOVAL THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE. MODERATOR'S ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. NINE SEVEN EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THERE TO SUPPORT SB.
NINE SEVEN EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED FOR OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
OPPOSED TO NINE SEVEN EIGHT
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT. CAPOS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CLEAN AND CUTE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND WE
SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE SEVEN EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT ALSO BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE ON BEER
MANUFACTURERS DIRECT SHIPPING
PERMITS IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO SUPPORT
TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT. IF YOU LIKE TO
SUPPORT LEVEL NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL
COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF
ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE OPPOSE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB ELEVEN NINETY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
IT'S SO. MANY CUTE ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT AND WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTIONS SB
ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB NINE OH
SIX BY PORTANTINO SCHOOL SAFETY
MASS CASUALTY THREATS. IS THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE OH SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE OH SIX. SO PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY NINETY Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE OH SIX IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED SB NINE OH SIX COME ON
UP. HIGH COURT ME PETER
STANISLAUS COUNTY I OPPOSE. YOU. TONY GRIEF FOR MODESTO AYE
OPPOSED. IN A LARGE CLUSTER
COUNTY FINANCE STRONG OF A POST
RIGHT COME ON. PLEASE JOIN US
THERE WITH THE- RELEASE ON
YOUTUBE AYE OPPOSED. YOU SEAN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY RESIDENT
OPPOSE ANYONE ELSE A COUPLE MORE
COME ON UP. HI MY NAME IS SERRA
FROM RANCHO CORDOVA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. JAMES FROM SECOND TO
CALIFORNIA I HAVE A CELL THANK
YOU. MAKING SURE EVERYBODY HERE
HAD THEIR OPPORTUNITY. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB NINE OH
SIX. PROPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ELAINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS GABRIELLE INGRAM
FOUNDER FEATHER SACRAMENTO
COUNTY REPRESENTING THOUSANDS
AROUND THE AREA AND WE DO NOT
WORK THAT. WE ARE ALIGNED FIFTY
WITH GO AHEAD. YOU'RE NOT FELT
MEMBER OF THE UP SACRAMENTO
COUNTY MY FAMILY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. YOUR LINE FOR
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATHY
COMMENT KERN COUNTY I AM.
MITCHELL LINE SEVEN FOUR GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS BRENDA PANDO
SOCCER CAN I OPPOSE THE SELF. AN
EXTRA LINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE RIGHT OF THE PEOPLE
KEEP BEAR ARMS SHALL NOT BE
INFRINGED YOU APPROACH. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM FROM
TULARE COUNTY AND I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THREE
NINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. TEAMS WHO WOULD BE SEVEN.
NEWMAN TO YEAH OUR LINE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY
BRENDA I'M A LACK OF MONEY I
HAVE. CURRENTLY FURTHER INTO.
BUT WE DO ONE OTHER ALLY ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK YOU CAN
ON A CASH OPPOSING THE- AND I'M
GOTTEN FOR INTO YOUR THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TO SUPPORT NAPA
OF S. B. OH SO OH QUESTIONS MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE OH SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB NINE SEVENTY FOUR
BY PORTANTINO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY HERE IN TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. THERE'S YES COME ON
UP- THAT GROUP ON BEHALF OF RACE
RADIOLOGY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORT WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE SEVEN FOUR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT SB
NINETY SEVEN FOUR AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU. RIGHT WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVEN
FORCE OR ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO YOU KNOW IN SOME OF
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR GOT OF
THE PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION SB
NINE SEVEN FOUR. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. SB. NINE
SEVEN FOUR ONE ZERO. YEAH ONE
EIGHT Q. GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT
HERE. OKAY- TAKING THEMSELF IQ.
ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IS THAT IT.
YEAH ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
SEVEN FOUR WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE LIVING ON SB
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN BY PORTANTINO
CALIFORNIA CANCER CARE EQUITY
ACT. WILL FIVE WAY PRESENTATION
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT C. RUSSIA THE MICROPHONE
MODERATE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT TESTIMONY FOR
IT SB. NINE EIGHTY. HIS SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE LEGAL LINE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE YOU READY
TO MAKE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT
BASES. CURRENTLY NINE FURTHER AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE GOT
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN C. NOBODY COME TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
EIGHT SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO OPPOSE AGAIN IT'S. ONE
ZERO. GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT HERE.
WE CAN OPEN LINE. NINETY SEVEN.
WORK GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ALEX CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION SORRY FOR GETTING IN
THE WRONG HERE BUT WE ARE A CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
NONE FURTHER AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF NINETY SEVEN
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN GO A SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB ELEVEN SIXTEEN BY
PORTANTINO ART COUNCIL A
PERFORMING ARTS EQUITABLE
PAYROLL FUND. IS MEN'S CANDIDATE
I'VE WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SIXTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SUPPORT. THIRTY NINE IN Q.
CON ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SIXTEEN
THERE'S NOBODY COMING TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO ELEVEN
SIXTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO OPPOSE SB. ELEVEN SIXTY.
THANK YOU CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN SIXTEEN GOES TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON S. B. TWELVE OH SEVEN
BY PORTANTINO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE MATERNAL PANDEMIC
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
THIS IS SUSPENSE CANDIDATE I'VE
WAY PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF TWELVE OH SEVEN
SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE OR SUPPORT OF
TWELVE OH SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT SB. TWELVE
OH SEVEN. NINETY TWO AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF TWELVE OH SEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM COME
INTO THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB TWELVE OH SEVEN. THE
POST PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
EARLY MORNING YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY WITH
OPPOSITE OF TWELVE OH SEVEN-
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE OH SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE THE NEXT IS THE CLAIMS
BILL WHICH ARE PRESENT. MISTER
WHITE CAL SKIERS ONE. READ
WITNESS I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
YOU. THIS IS SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE
APPROPRIATION CENTER PORTANTINO
THERE'S A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
. HE'S PRESENT THE PHYSICAL
ASPECTS OF THIS NATURE ALL RIGHT
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE IS ONE
OF THE BILLS CARRIED BY THE
CHAIRS OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIR TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY FOR
LEGAL SETTLEMENTS APPROVED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS
URGENCY BILL APPROPRIATE EIGHT
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE GENERAL FUND TO DOJ FOR THE
PAYMENT OF THE FOLLOWING CLAIMS
AGAINST THE STATE AMERICANS FOR
PROSPERITY VERSUS HARRIS AND
CEDAR POINT NURSERY VERSUS HOW I
SEE. THE SETTLEMENTS FOR
ATTORNEYS FEES AND COSTS WERE
ENTERED INTO LAWFULLY BY THE
STATE UPON ADVICE OF COUNSEL AND
ARE BINDING STATE OBLIGATIONS
ANY FUNDS APPROPRIATED IN EXCESS
OF THE AMOUNTS REQUIRED FOR THE
CLAIM TO REVERT TO THE GENERAL
FUND. I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO OFFER
AN AUTHORS AMENDMENT TO CORRECT
A TECHNICAL ERROR IN THE WAY
THAT WORKS CASES ARE CITED IN
THE BILL WITH ME TODAY IS AMY
ALLEY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND I BELIEVE. HE HAS
BACK UP ON THE COAST LINE FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS MICELI
YOUR RECOGNIZED IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE. LATE IN THE
MORNING CARE PART. BEGINNING
AMBER FINE MY NAME IN THE ALLEY
AND THE LIKE THEY HAVE CRAFTED
FOR THE- YEAH THANK. AND I THE
RAINY. FONG AT THE THIRD FIFTY
FIVE ADELE'S HER FREE EIGHT
MILLION A HUNDRED SOUTH DOLLARS
. GENERAL AND- THE- DAN FOR THE
- OF CLAIMS SETTLEMENT. PROJECT
THANK YOU FOR THE STATE I WRITE
FROM THE BACKSIDE. IN LIKE EIGHT
REPRESENTED BY THE- GENERAL.
FUND YOU EVER NEEDED ANYTHING
FROM THE GOVERNMENT BALK AT AND
I'M NOT. AT ANY CAN BE MEMBERS
HAVE. AFFECT CLASS IN REGARDING
I. MAY FROM THE OTHER RIGHT IN
YOU SENATOR PER. FOR OFFERING
THAT SUPPORT FELT AND THANK YOU
FOR IT'S MEETING MEMBER. ON
BEHALF MUTUAL GENERAL ARE AT FOR
YOUR I. OF. VERY GOOD OTHER MEN
HERE ROOM FIVE TWENTY TWO. AND
OF. SB THREE FOR FIVE PLEASE
COME FOR TO TEST. THE MY- PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR MEN
WANTING TO TESTIFY AT THE PUMP.
MONEY TO TEST INSTEAD OF S.
THIRTY FIFTY FIVE-
LEAD WITNESS- LISTED IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OPPOSED TO. SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE- CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE
THE APPROPRIATION. CNN MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THE
PHONE LINE DID HE TESTIFY
AGAINST S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE. AND IF SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OKAY LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
MEMBERS OF THETECHNICAL
QUESTION CENTER LATER DR NO
TECHNICAL QUESTION I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL OKAY THERE'S A MOTION.
SEEING THE REQUEST FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION. TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER THE
BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO HIS
CENTER BATES. CENTER BRADFORD
CENTER BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES RIGHT CENTER JONES EYES
CENTER KAMLAGER. CENTER LAYERED
HI CENTER LAYERED HIS SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI CENTER BY CAL
SKI I. BILL CURRENTLY HAS FIVE
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN ON
FILE. ALL RIGHT THAT BILL IS ON
CALL WILL MOVE TO SB NINE TWELVE
BY SENATOR RAMON ON BIOMARKER
TESTING THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAVE TEST FROM A
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. WE WILL- GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF NINE TWELVE WILL MOVE
ON TO PHONE LINES MODERATE
HEARING ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE TWELVE.
SB NINE WELL. I CAN GO TO LINE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. TAKE A
PICTURE SANTIAGO TO LINE SEVENTY
. SEVEN ZERO YOU'RE OPEN. IF I
HAD. THERE ARE HOPEFUL WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
COURT. IN MEXICO TO LINE EIGHTY
IF I HAD. AB YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AMONG N. Y. CANCER THAT WERE IN
JOHN. IMAGE ONLINE. NINETY GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE LOWER
MONTHS WITH HELP REIMAGINE AND
TECHNOLOGY THIRTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IN CURRENTLY
AND FURTHER Q. WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION NOW SB NINE TWELVE IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO NINE TWELVE SEEING NO
ONE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB NINE TWELVE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TWO HELLO. AND FURTHER OUR NINETY WITH
THE PLAN ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
TWELVE SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE TWELVE AGO TO SUSPENSE SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX FROM RAMON ON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION OF A RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX. NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THEPHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO ELEVEN SEVENTY
SIX. THE PROPOSAL PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN THE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIXERS NO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. BILLION SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR LIMÓN ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION DISABILITY
BENEFITS AND GENDER DISPARITY.
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
SUPPORT. OVER IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OF. FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIRECTORS TIME TO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION NOW REST
BEFORE TÍNH FIFTY EIGHT IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. ONE
ZERO TO OPPOSE. CURRENTLY MANY
CUTE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT AN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ELEVEN ASUMI FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT WE MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE MOVING ON
TO SB NINE SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
BACKGROUND SEAMLESS TRANSIT
TRANSFORMATION ACT IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED C.
NOBODY RUSSIAN THE MICROPHONE.
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SUPPORT SB. NINETY SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION TO BE. NINE
SEVENTEEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR LET'S CUT THE PHONE
LINE FOR OPPOSITION TO NINE
SEVENTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO CLOSE. THANK CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SB NINE SEVENTEEN AND
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE SEVENTEEN WILL GO TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE MOVING ON THE SP
ONE THOUSAND BY SENATOR BACK
AROUND LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE. MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THOUSAND. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SUPPORT SB ONE THOUSAND AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO. ONE ISSUE HERE
GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT.
A LINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU I'M IS MARCUS
FORTY ONE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
REPRESENTING COP WATCH. AND
STRONGLY- ABOUT THE HOT. WATER
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. AND
CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK OPPOSITE
OF SB ONE THOUSAND IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO
ONE THOUSAND NO ONE'S COMING IN
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB ONE
THOUSAND. MODERATOR. I THINK I
MAY BE DONE IT'S ONE ZERO TWO
OPPOSE. HE CURRENTLY NINETY Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE THOUSAND
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ONE THOUSAND WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING ON SB ONE
THOUSAND AND EIGHT BY SENATOR
BACKGROUND CORRECTIONS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS IS THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAVE PRESENTATION. WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM AT
THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME SO. YES ONE ZERO. YOU
CAN GO TO LINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE RESEARCHER
MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS
SPOTS EVER GET THE LESSONS AND
ALONG PARTY OR TRY TO BE A CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. HE GIVE ME A MOMENT
HERE WITH. ANOTHER ONE IN Q.
HERE. THANK. WILL OPEN UP NINE
ONE OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUDGET PROTERRA GENERAL MANAGER
SEAN YOUNG WITH FINANCIAL
JUSTICE PROJECT OF SAN
DISCLOSURE I RESTRUCTURING THE
OFFICE AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
TO KEEP FAMILIES CONNECTED ACT
THANK YOU. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER IN Q. RIGHT WILL COME
BACK TO THE ROOM FOR OPPOSITION
TO ONE THOUSAND EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE OPPOSED
TO ONE THOUSAND EIGHT MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB ONE THOUSAND EIGHT.
THE FIRST ONE ZERO SO. CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ONE THOUSAND IT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE LIVING ON S. B. ELEVEN
TWELVE BY CENTER BACK ON ENERGY
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION NOTICE
AND RECORD ATION OF A
DECARBONISATION CHARGE IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
SEEING NO ONE RUSHED TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO WITH A
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THERE AT THIS TIME TO SUPPORT SB. ELEVEN TWELVE. CERTAINLY NOT A
FEW ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN TWELVE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO ELEVEN TWELVE.
LIKE TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
NINETEEN KIDS ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF
ELEVEN TWELVE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
TWELVE. HELLO TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE MOVING TO S. B. TWELVE
THOUSAND THREE ON ZERO NET
EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES SUPPORT OF
TWELVE OH THREE. REPORT SB
TWELVE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT A LINE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY THREE YEAR OPEN. YEH I
APPROACH IT. SHE HELLO WE ARE
CHEN. AND CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE OH THREE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TROUBLE THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON THE SENATOR
NEWMAN S. B. NINE TWENTY ONE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR DIGITAL POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENTS THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
SUPPORT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATE FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
TWO ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SUPPORT SB NINE TWENTY ONE. I
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. WILL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION WILL OPEN IT
UP IN THIS ROOM COME ON UP. SB.
NINE TWENTY ONE. YES HI THIS IS
RELAUNCH PLUS RECOUNTING
REPRESENTING TO RALLY RUNNING
FOR US SENATE. WERE STRONG
OPPOSITION THIS BILL THERE'S NO
NEED TO CHANGE ANYTHING THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NO ONE ELSE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE POST SB. NINE TWENTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO SUPPOSED SB NINE TWENTY
ONE. FOR PERSONAL LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY TAKEN
THEMSELVES OUT THE SCHOOL BACK
HERE FILE LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GABRIELLE FOUNDER
CANNOT SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND WE
OPPOSE. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
DOING A FIFTY SEVEN YEAR OLD
WILL OPEN UP. WHEN A MYSTERY BUT
A MAJOR. I FELT MEMBER OF
ACKERMAN COUNTY AND WE HAVE THIS
BILL. AND NOW WE GO. TO ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. MY NAME IS BRENDA
PANDA FIND FROM COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. HE
LIKES WHAT FINE EIGHTY THREE. MY
NAME IS WHEN MY FROM- FRAZIER
COUNTY AND I HAVE. IN LEGAL.
SIXTY TERIA KOBE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. ACTUALLY GOT LINE SIXTY
SEVEN. HI ABOUT ME REYES YES
YEAH PHONES DON'T WORK THANK YOU
BY THE WAY AND WE OPPOSE ACCESS
NEXT PERSON BY THE WAY FOLKS AT
HOME IT'S ONCE YOU GET PRESSURE
YOUR CODE NUMBER IF YOU COULD
DELUDE MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
LISTENING TO US ON WILL GET LESS
FEEDBACK SO ONCE YOU GET PUT IN
THE QUEUE TO LEAVE THE VICE
YOU'RE YOU'RE LISTENING ON. ALL
RIGHT ANYBODY ELSE SUPPOSED TO
NINE TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE TWENTY ONE
AND WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS BEHIND TWENTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR
MOVE NEWMAN. ON THE SAFE AT HOME
PROGRAM A LECTURE AND ELECTION
WORKERS AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. WE DO HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WHICH WE'LL GET TO
BUT RIGHT NOW WE WILL GO TO.
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
IN SUPPORT. MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE. JUST SUPPORT
AFTER ELEVEN THIRTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY MANY
CUTE ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S A LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION SUSAN ON
ALL FROM THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE- SHE'S THE ONLY PRIMARY
WITNESS- SO WE WILL Q. HER UP
AND SHE HAS THREE MINUTES. THANK
YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO BY THE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN DOWN THE
ONLY GOOD JOB MODERATING I
REALLY. YOU AGAIN MY NAME IS AN
ART ALL THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
LEGAL AFFAIRS AT THE RIGHT TO
LIFE AMERICA'S. FIRST PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION WE ASK THIS
COMMITTEE TO RECOMMEND A SIMPLE
INCLUSIVE AMENDMENT TO SB
ELEVEN. ALL COST YOU ANY MORE
MONEY. WE WANT YOU TO WEEKS. THE
HOME CROWD TO THE WHOSE.
PREGNANT HERE FOR LIFE I RIGHT
NOW WE. AS WELL AS THOSE WHO UP
HERE LAST WEEK RADICAL PRO
ABORTION ACTED VIOLENTLY DOWN
THE- PRO LIFE RIGHT THANK.
CENTERS IN PORTLAND OREGON AND
WAS KIND. LAST WEEK CONNECTED
INTO UP ON ARE THREATENING MORE
BY AGAIN THE PRO LIFE CLINICS
CRISIS PREGNANCY CLINICS IN OUR
- HAVE BEEN. AND BAMBOO MORE SIX
TIMES THE. TWENTY TWENTY. CLEAN
OF VANDALISM ALL HARASS CRAFT
AND INDEED YEAR AT THE RIGHT.
HOURS WHAT CAN AND BOND. WORK IS
THIS THREATENED AN ASSAULT OUR
SIGN WITH THE STOLEN OFF TIMES
FOR ADVOCATING A PRO NEXT. I
THOUGHT WE BEEN THREATENED WITH
NINE AND BEING BACK WITH EIGHT
JUST FOR STAND AND FOR PRAYING.
CURRENTLY S. ELEVEN THIRTY
CREATE THE NEXT. SPECIAL CLASS
THAT IS. IN TO A ROLE IN THE
STATE PRO. FOR ANYONE WHO SPEAKS
UP. IF THEY ARE FEARFUL FOR
THEIR HEALTH SAFETY BECAUSE
THEIR AFFILIATE WITH EVERY.
HEALTH CARE FACILITY I FEEL
THIRTY SHOULD BE IN. PROTECT
OPTION FOR ANY FEARFUL THEIR
HEALTH OR SAFETY WHEN SEEKING
HELP CARE REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY- THAT HEALTH CARE. AS WE
AWAIT THE FINE RULING REGARDING
THE WORLD WADE WE URGE THE TO
EXTEND THAT LEGAL PROTECT TO
FIVE OF THE ABORTION. IN THE
NAME OF EQUITY AND WILL NOT COST
ANYTHING MORE PLEASE AMEND SB
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THAT OUR
LEAD WITNESS IN OP. WHAT BACK TO
TWENTY HUNDRED IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED. THAT YOU'RE NAY AND
YOUR PHILLY IN YOUR- MY NAME IS
SEAN SEKHEMRE COUNTY ROAD. HI
OPPOSE THIS AND I SAW HER
SUGGESTION. PLEASE CHILD WAS
RELEASED ON NEW TUBE I OPPOSE.
ELEVEN ONE. SURE LOTS
REPRESENTING THROUGH ROWING
RUNNING FOR US SENATE ON
CAMPAIGN. AND ALSO RIGHT FOR
LIFE SO- COMPOSING MISS THANK
YOU WITHOUT WITHOUT LIKE
AMENDMENTS ADDED TO PROTECT ALL
LIFE THANK YOU THANK YOU. IF YOU
CAN CAN FIND YOURSELF TO YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED THANKS
COURTNEY PETER STANISLAUS COUNTY
WILL TAKE A STAND STANISLAUS WE
OPPOSE THE SPELL. THANK HI MY
NAME IS SERRA FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RACHEL IVERMECTIN GATES ORANGE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK. JUST
WIDER SECTION CALIFORNIA OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. VERY MUCH NO ONE
ELSE IN THIS ROOM MODERATE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR ANY
FURTHER OPPOSITION SB. ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO OPPOSE. HE GOT A LINE
FIFTY NINE IF I HAD. I'M A LONG
TIME PRO CHOICE LIBERAL
DEMOCRATIC I HAVE HAD FOR XIN
THANK AND AYE OPPOSED. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JEANETTE.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND AYE
OPPOSED THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH ONE.
THIS IS DAVID BALL OUT FROM THE
- JUSTICE FOR ALL AYE OPPOSED
THIS BILL. THE NEW GOOD LUCK THE
LINE. FIVE COBIA PRO LIFE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MEXICO LINE
ALLOW PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS LAURIE GREEN. FROM CINEMA
COUNTY HOW I WOULD LIKE THIS
BILL AMENDED OUT THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU PRESENTE BY OPPOSE.
XFL. EIGHTY THREE. GLENDALE
GATHERED COUNTY AND I OPPOSED
BILL. INCRETIN AND FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE WITHOUT NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE REMOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE MOVING ON SB
TWELVE FIFTEEN BY SENATOR NEWMAN
RESPONSIBLE BATTERY RECYCLING
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE- IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE- THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL MOVE RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE PHONE LINE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE FIFTEEN. BEING IS PRESS.
ONE ZERO NINE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
SB TWELVE FIFTEEN. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE POST
TEST B. TWELVE FIFTEEN. TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS IN THIS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE FIFTEEN WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT FILL. WHICH IS. STAPLE
MAKES IT HARD TO READ SB NINE
FOUR SEVEN BY SENATOR WELCOME
WHISTLEBLOWER PRIVATE ENTITIES
AWARDED LARGE STATE CONTRACTS IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
MOVE TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FORTY SEVEN.
TO SUPPORT SB NINE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WELL GO
TO LINE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI ACCESSIBLE RACINO FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA I DO SUPPORT SB NINE
FORTY SEVEN. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER ISSUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE FORTY SEVEN IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM NO ONE'S
COMING TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO NINE FORTY
SEVEN. THE POST PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
NONE IN OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. NINE FORTY SEVEN
MOVED TO SUSPEND TO SPEAK TEN
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR WELKER-
MINORITY LEADER WELL MEDIC CAL I
CLASS PRISON INDUSTRY AUTHORITY.
SUSPENDS CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE UP IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN EIGHTY NINE. YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY NOBODY
IN Q. GOT OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
EIGHTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY AT
THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB TEN EIGHTY NINE. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO APOLLO. NOT
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
TEN EIGHTY NINE THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
WE CAN EIGHTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE BY MINORITY LEADER
WEALTH AND CONTRACTS FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF GOODS OR SERVICES
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE SEVENTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THERE AT THIS TIME TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU CURRENTLY.
ALL RIGHT WAS THAT A POSITION I
GOT. THE SYSTEM THAT WAS SUPPORT
OKAY WILL COME BACK TO THIS ROOM
FOR OPPOSITION TO TWELVE SEVENTY
ONE THAT'S THE FIRST TIME I
FORGOT WHERE I WAS TODAY THAT'S
NOT BAD PAGE FOR I GOT STAGE
FOUR BEFORE IT HAPPENS. WE'LL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO TWELVE
SETTING ONE UP MODERATOR'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE. HELLO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THEN
AT THAT TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL
COME BACK TO THIS ROOM SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB NINE FIFTY
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA CALFRESH
INCOME ELIGIBILITY IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN THIS
ROOM. NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT SB NINE FIFTY. CURRENTLY
NINE Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FIFTY THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO NINE FIFTY
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB. NINE FIFTY.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO SO. AND
THEN IN Q. WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WITH NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION NINE FIFTY WILL GO TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE MOVING SB NINE
EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
MILITARY SERVICE LEAVE OF
ABSENCE PAY AND BENEFITS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY FROM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF NINE
EIGHTY FOUR. BUT WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL REPORT HOLD ON ONE
SECOND MODERATOR WE HAVE EVERY
SUPPORTER IN THE ROOM COME ON.
YOUR. HELLO THIS ISSUE IN MARCH
YOU CAN FIND REPRESENTING A
THREE BROTHERS SENATE AND- WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF. NINETY
FOUR THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
MODERATOR SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
EIGHTY FOUR. PRESS ONE ZERO IF
SO. THANK YOU OKAY SO YOU TOO
SHOULD BECAUSE. HE DIDN'T HEAR
ME I SAID YOU GUYS SWITCH FOR
MAKE IT ON. I WOULD HAVE DONE IT
WHILE AGO HE'S. I KNOW YOU'RE HE
SHOULD JUST GO BACK ONE TO MAKE
. ARE MONTEREY RON SUPPORT OF
NINE EIGHTY FOUR. I CURRENTLY
NINE Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION FOR SB NINE
EIGHTY FOUR- THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO NINE EIGHTY FOUR. THE FIRST
ONE ZERO SO. AND I THINK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NINETY
FORESEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINETY FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY ARCHER LEAD ON PROPERTY
TAXATION EXEMPTION DISABILITY
VETERANS HOMEOWNERS. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT
THE MICROPHONE. MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO SUPPORT. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REALLY WRITTEN
IN SUPPORT. YES ONE ZERO WE AT
ONE POINT Q. HERE GIVE ME A
MINUTE- LINE CALIFORNIA LANDS
OPEN. RIGHT HANDER IN SUPPORT.
IN LINE ONE OH FIVE YOU ARE OPEN
. CHAVEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT. GOT LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COME MARCH
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
OPEN. FIFTY SEVEN GO AHEAD.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
AND THEN FURTHER ISSUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE HAVE THREE
SUPPORTERS IN THIS ROOM WE WANT
TO COME UP COME ON OUT SEAN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND SUGGEST HEX
EXEMPTION FOR ALL SENIORS. ALL
RIGHT I'M AND ONE OF THE TIME.
SURE LARGE PURPOSE ENGINES
REALLY RUNNING FOR US ENATE WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
THIS LIKE WE NEED TO TAKE CARE
OF IT THANK YOU. PLEASE TELL
TODAY WAS RELEASED I NEED TO BUY
SUPPORT THURSDAY FIFTY SEVEN
FALL VETERANS AND SENIORS. HI MY
NAME IS SERRA FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
. ALL RIGHT TAKE IN THE PORT
POSITIONS WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TOPOS. I AM
CURRENTLY LEARNING QUEUE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN I HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WE GOT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON THE S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE BY SENATOR ARCHER
LEAD ON ENERGY APPLIANCES LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. THERE'S NOBODY HERE AT
THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
. PLEASE PRESS ONE STRUCTURE
SUPPORT. A MOMENT HERE. AND WE
GO TO LINE ONE OH NINE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS HER MEMBERS
YELEY GATHERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. AND
CURRENTLY KNOWN FOR LEARNING
GIVES. REPORT ALL RIGHT W HAVE
ONE MORE SUPPORTER IN THIS ROOM
COME ON UP. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STILL BE OFFERING TO HAVE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. OKAY WHEN I
GOT OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM NO MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSED SB.
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE. CURRENTLY
NINE Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION MOVE NO
BEHALF IT UP ONE. THANK GOD WE
DO HAVE ONE HERE GIVE ME JUST A
MOMENT. ALL RIGHT THEY GOT IN
UNDER THE WIRE. WELL MAKERS TO
GET THEIR NUMBER HERE GOT A
FASTER THUMBS. AT. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROD BREWER FOR
CALIFORNIA THE NEW YORK OPPOSE.
AND THEN FOR THEIR KIDS THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES HAVING CLOSED
THE PUBLIC COMMENT WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
CENTER ARCHULETA ON DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISES
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION- WE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. COME ON UP
. HI ONCE AGAIN CHALLENGE HOSTED
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES PROBABLY
TWENTY FOR U. S. SENATE.
RESTAURANTS OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU YOU. SCHANTZ COUNTY RESIDENT
STRONG SUPPORT WE SHOULD SAYS
SUPPORTER BETTER. HI MY NAME IS
SERRA FROM RANCHO CORDOVA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. LUCILE TODAY
WAS RELEASED ON YOUTUBE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT NO
ONE ELSE COME UP MODERATION
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT ACT THE FOURTEENTH.
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU RIGHT
WILL NOT OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM SEEING NO
ONE COMING OF MICROPHONE
MODERATORS OR ANY OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. AND
CURRENTLY YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NO QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON THE SENATOR MEN S. B. NINE
FIFTY THREE ON OIL AND GAS
LEASES. IS THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT HERE ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIFTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME THE
SUPPORT. YOU CAN BE JUST A
MOMENT HERE.
WE CAN OPEN LINE ONE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LAURA OFFICE WITH THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION REPORT ITSELF. AND
THEN FOR THEIR QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK
FOR OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIFTY
THREE COME ON UP. THANK YOU
SENATORS MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE
AT THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. NO ONE ELSE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE ANYBODY ELSE
SUPPOSED TO NINE FIFTY THREE. WE
GOT ONE MORE IN THIS ROOM COME
ON UP JOHN SECOND ACCOUNTING I
OPPOSE. THANK YOU JOHN MODERATOR
ANYONE ELSE NINE FIFTY THREE.
OPPOSE THE FACT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE TOTAL POST. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE ONE CAN KEEP
GIVING ME A MOMENT.
BRADFORD WHICH BRING THE. AND WE
CAN OPEN LINE. ONE THIRTEEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS FALL THE
EURO REPRESENTING THE WESTERN
CONTROLLING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIVE
THREE. THANK YOU. AND THEN
PROVIDE YOU WITH A FINE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF NINE FIFTY THREE I
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE FIFTY THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING SB
ONE THOUSAND ONE BY SENATOR MEN
ON CALIFORNIA'S CYBER SECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB ONE THOUSAND ONE THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF ONE THOUSAND
ONE. IF PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT ONE THOUSAND ONE. YES
ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY MANY CUTE
WILL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF
SB ONE THOUSAND ONE THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS ANYONE OPPOSED SB ONE
THOUSAND ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IT'S SO. HE CURRENTLY
MANAGE- WE TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE THOUSAND
ONE AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE
THOUSAND ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY SENATOR MAN ON FIRE ARMS
DEALER REQUIREMENTS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT WITHOUT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY RUSSIAN INTHE
MICROPHONE MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. THE
CURRENT NINE Q. ALL RIGHT I
MISSED ONE PERSON IN THE ROOM
COME ON UP. HI THREE LAUNCH
PLASTER COUNTY REPRESENTING ZERO
AARON BREDESON. AND I WOULD BE
AND- STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT'S A- GOING
AGAINST OUR SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS THANK YOU SO. ALL RIGHT
I'M GONNA SHANTHAKUMARAN COUNTY
OPPOSE. COMMA THANK YOU. I
POLICE TO THEY WOULD DO IS I
NEED TO BE AYE OPPOSED. HI MY
NAME IS SERRA FOR MAJOR CORDOVA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. RACHEL
IVERMECTIN GATES ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE. RIGHT I
ALREADY DID THE PHONE LINE. AND
SO WE HAVE TAKEN OUT OF OUR
QUEUE NOW- WE DO. YOU'RE NOW I'M
FEELING THE WEIGHT OF THE ANYWAY
ALL RIGHT WELL TO ON. ONE NINE.
AB DE CORNER OPPOSE. LIFE
TESTIMONY THAT WAS SHORTEST ONE.
NEXT ISN'T. FIFTY YOU MAKE IS
ONE OH ONE YOU KNOW IF YOU
YELLOW IT MAY YOUR POINT MORE
STRONG. ALLOWS YOU TO GO OUT.
THE ALL IT WOULD JUST FOR ALL MY. EIGHTEEN THAT COULD ALLOW.
EIGHTY THREE. YEAH THIS IS GOING
TO I ASKED HER. AND NUMBER THE
REST TIME ALL RIGHT WE GONE BACK
AND FORTH TWICE ON THAT SO NO
CAN COMPLAIN. ABOUT SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OF THANK YOU THAT OF
S. B. EIGHTY FOR WILL MOVE
ASSIST. MOVIE HONEST LAW SB NINE
FIFTY ON PUBLIC AND REAL FOR THE
GOOD SENATE WAY PRESENT. AND IT
IS THIS IS CAN WILL GO TO
TESTIMONY SUPPORT WE HAVE
SOMEONE AT MICROPHONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MAY
LUKASZ WITH THE ARE ASSOCIATION
OF SHEET AIR RAIL AND
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION SMART TV
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THING NO
ONE ELSE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY
SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
SUPPORT. I'M IN MANICURED TIMES
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION OF THIS DISTRICT BILL
ANYONE HERE KNOW NO ONE ON THE
PHONE THAT'S KIND OF THE PHONE
LINE FOR OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FIFTY SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO OPPOSE SB NINE FIFTY
SEVEN. RIDLEY NINETY Q. WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB NINE FIFTY SEVEN HAS GONE TO
SUSPENSE WILL MOVE ON TO S. B.
TEN TWENTY THE AUTHOR IS NOT WAY
PRESENTATION AND IS HERE TO TELL
US ABOUT SB TEN TWENTY ON CLEAN
ENERGY JOBS AND AFFORDABILITY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THOUGHT
THIS WAS A BIG ENOUGH BILL AN
IMPORTANT OFF A BILL THAT I
NEEDED TO CALL ATTENTION TO IT
IT ENACTS THE- CLEAN ENERGY JOBS
AND AFFORDABILITY ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IT IS A MAJOR JOINTLY
AUTHORED BY THE PRO TEM SENATORS
CABALLERO AND TO RISE SO AND
MYSELF. AND THERE ARE ELEVEN CO
AUTHORS NINE OF WHICH ARE THE
REMAINING SENATORS THAT ARE IN
THE CLIMATE. OF A WORKING GROUP
OF THIS BILL IS THE PRODUCT OF
THE SENATE WORKING GROUP ON
CLIMATE CHANGE WOULD GIVE
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY TO
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRIC SECTOR
CLIMATE COMMITMENTS AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME PLACE RATE PAYER
AFFORDABILITY AT THE CORE OF OUR
STATE POLICY. THE BILL HAS THREE
MAIN COMPONENTS IT ADDS INTERIM
TARGETS TO THE POLICY FRAMEWORK
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED IN SENATE
BILL ONE HUNDRED IT REQUIRES
STATE AGENCIES TO RELY ON A 100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY. AND ZERO
CARBON RESOURCES TO SERVE THEIR
OWN FACILITIES BY TWENTY THIRTY
AND IT IS TIME WHICH IS A
CLIMATE IN EQUITY TRUST FUND TO
ADDRESS RISING ELECTRICITY RATES
TO THREATEN THE AFFORDABILITY OF
BASIC SERVICE AND UNDERMINE THE
ECONOMICS OF BENEFICIAL BUILDING
AND TRANSPORTATION.
ELECTRIFICATION TAKE AS A- OF
THIS INTO TO BRING NEW TERM
RIGOR TO CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK
ELECTRICITY. CLEAN ENERGY AND
ZERO CARBON TARGETS THE FOCUS ON
THE AFFORDABILITY OF MEETING
THOSE TARGETS AND TO MAKE OTHER
CHANGES TO THE LAW TO MEET OUR
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS. OF THE
SENATE'S BUDGET PROPOSAL. THAT
HAS COME OUT FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS ADDRESSES PARTS OF THIS
BILL AND OTHER CLIMATE
ACTIVITIES WITH A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT. AND D. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KICKSTARTER CLIMATE
ACTIVITIES THIS BILL DOES IT WAS
SOME SUPPORT ACROSS THE CARCASS.
AND I WOULD- RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT THE BILL MOVES TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE NASA COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. IN PASSING OFF
SUSPENSE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
AND I THANK YOU FOR THE ABILITY
TO COMMENT TODAY YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY OF THE WITNESSES CORRECT.
CORRECT ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
THE PRESENTATION FROM THE AUTHOR
AND WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN TWENTY.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IT'S SO.
THANK YOU CURRENTLY WELCOME BACK
FOR OPPOSITION ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO TEN TWENTY. COME
ON UP. YOU WOULDN'T BE FROM YOU
TO PLEASE. JULIA STILES PHONE
TODAY WAS RELEASED ON YOUTUBE-
FOES. SB TEN TWENTY HERE YOU LET
. SCHANTZ RECKONING I OPPOSED BY
THE SUPPORT THAT MAN. HE SAID
YOU TO JUST CASE YOU DIDN'T OKAY
LET ME I DON'T KNOW THAT. HI MY
NAME IS THERE ARE. COULD
OVERNIGHT. OUR LIMON ELSE IN
THIS ROOM OF THE GO TO THE FOR
LINE FOR OPPOSITE. SB TEN
TWENTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE TWO
OPPOSE. BOTH TO LINE EIGHT.
GABRIELLE ENGRAM AM NOT PRIVY TO
FIELD I HAVE THE BILL. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE OH SEVEN SOUND LIKE
A HASH TAG. HI THIS IS JAMIE CAN
CALLING FROM FOR COUNTY ON
BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP FOR AND WE
ARE OPPOSED. OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED ITSELF. A COUPLE ONE.
CLOSE HI. FROM SAN DIEGO AND I
HOPE THE BILL'S. IF WE CAN- OPEN
IT. NINE I AM SURE. SIX ONE NINE
ABOUT. BENNIFER CORNER OUT THE
NIGHT. THE MEXICAN LOW OPEN
EIGHTY THREE. THEN THE MASTER
PLAN BROWN I. EXPECT A LOT. ONE
OH ONE. DATEABLE ON IN FROM ONE
ST CA EMPLOYER LOS CA OF LAW AND
POWER. OF THE HIGH LOW EIGHTEEN
I'M A. IN THE COOLER FOR SIXTY.
SIX FIVE YEAR. GO AHEAD I
APOLOGIZE. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN
VERY KINDLY FOR YOUR PAY- HI I
MISSED WHEN I MEAN I'M IMPRESSED
WITH PATIENT I'M AYE OPPOSED THE
BILL THANK VERY MUCH FOR THE TO
ME OF MADERA ON YOU TO GET HELP
BUT I'M NOT THERE YOU GO. HE IN
NEXT TIME. LINE SEVEN. HI MY
NAME IS JEANETTE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NOPE NOT A FURTHER Q.
R. I. WE'VE TAKEN OPPOSITION I
WOULD ECHO SO LEYRITZ COMMENTS
THIS IS A IMPORTANT MEASURE AND
I'VE THE WORK OF THE CLIMATE
WHERE GROUP- WITHOUT OTHER. WITH
OUT OF S. B. TEN TO WILL GO TO
SUSPEND. AND WE DO TO MAKE THIS
A WARM FRIENDLY. COMMITTEE SO
FOR THE RECORD MOVING ON AS NINE
SEVEN SIX FROM SENATOR LEYVA ON
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL MOVE TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE SEVENTY SIX. NOBODY COMING
TO THE MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE SEVEN SIX. PART PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
SEVEN SIX CARMANAH. HI SURE
LATCH WHEN THEY'RE THREE
REPRESENTING THROUGH BRADLEY
RUNNING FOR US SENATE. WERE
STRONG OPPOSITION THIS BILL
NEEDS TO BE AMENDED.
DISCRIMINATORY TOWARDS. YOU KNOW
OTHER OTHER CLASSES OF PEOPLE.
COURTNEY PETERS STANISLAUS
COUNTY WITH PAKISTAN STANISLAUS
WE OPPOSE THE SPELL. JENNY GREAT
MOTHER OF THREE AND OPPOSE THE
BILL. MY NAME IS SERRA FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. PLEASE DIAL TODAY WAS
RELEASED ON YOU TOO FATHER OF
ONE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE LAST TIME I CHECKED I
DON'T CO PARENT WITH GOVERNMENT
. TRON FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM AGO NOW THE PHONE LINE.
MODERATE OR ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED. TO NINE SEVENTY SIX. WE PRESS
ONE ZERO SO. LITTLE LINE FIFTY
NINE. YOU A LEAGUE RECORD THANK
YOU SAYING MARC. MEXICO WILL- HE
- I IF GABRIELLE INGROWN CAN
AFFECT MEN ACCOUNTING I'VE SO.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE EIGHT THREE.
THE MATTER FASHION PARTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THE LINE
NINETEEN. JENNIFER CORNER
OPPOSED. TO A LINE ONE HUNDRED.
I AM CAROL OPPOSE. GOT. ONE
SEVENTEEN. ROAD PRETTY QUICKLY-
I OPPOSE. IN THE NEXT WE HAVE.
SIXTY FIVE. THE COSBY AND
PARENTS ARE THE THIRD AYE
OPPOSED DIFFICULTY. YOU
CURRENTLY MAN FURTHER YOU CAN'T
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVENTY
SIX SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB NINE EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS- I MIGHT JOIN AUTHOR
THIS BILL. AND WE WAIVE
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN NEW YORK
RIGHT NOW GROUP. PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT NO OF
COURSE NOT USUALLY IN SUPPORT
OF- REGULATION MY NAME IS JOHN-
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY BUT I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
JOHN. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE PHONE LINE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHTY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TWO SEP SB. NINE EIGHTY SIX. NINETY Q.
CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE EIGHTY
SIXTY NO ONE RUSHED HERE'S A
SUPPORT COME ON UP. YOU KNOW THE
DRILL. VETERANS MY NAME IS SERRA
RANCHO CORDOVA AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. RIGHT ABOUT
OPPOSITION MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
NINE EIGHTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO INFO. AND CURRENTLY
NINETY WE DO HAVE ONE HERE I'LL
GO TO LINE. EIGHTY THREE. NUMBER
AND CLASS OF PARTY AYE OPPOSED
TO FILL- AND THEN FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF NINE EIGHTY SIX
WITHOUT OBJECTION NO COURSING OF
COMMERCE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINETY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
CENTERONE BURKE HAS TEN FIFTY
SIX ONVIOLENT POSTS. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL OPEN
THE PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY IN SUPPORT OF TEN FIFTY
SIX MODERATE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY
SIX. PRESS. ONE ZERO TWO. ABOUT
A YEAR BEFORE THAT HAVE FAMILY
MANY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL NOW GO
TO OF TEN SIX COMMON. HIS PLUS
ANY REPRESENTATIVES PEOPLE
RUNNING FOR SENATE. WERE STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AGAINST
ANYBODY THE SECOND FREEDOM OF
SPEECH. JOHN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
STRONG OPPOSITION. FOR MINOR.
YOU KNOW I'M ACTUALLY JOHNSON
THEY WOULD RAISE MONEY TO AND I
OPPOSED REALLY. HI MY NAME IS
SERRA FOR MAJOR AND I. TULARE
POLICE- POSE IT. ALL RIGHT.
RACHEL IVERMECTIN GATES WEREN'T
PRESCHOOL TEACHER AND A- HAVE TO
OPPOSE OVERALL THANK YOU
REVOLUTION FISCAL ADLER CITING
REPRESENTING SAN JOAQUIN LIBERTY
COALITION AND WE OPPOSE. WHO
SAYS APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CAN'T BRING OUT SMILES AND- ALL
RIGHT MODERATE OR GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TEN FIFTY SIX. PARTLY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE.
CRYSTALLINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS WE THE PEOPLE
. AND WE THANK YOU. YOUR LINE
FIFTY SEVEN JUST WISH YOU GREEN
. MY NAME IS THAT HELP BAD ME I
HAVE SOME WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE TO FOR SOBER I TODAY WITH
WE'VE PEOPLE. HE MET WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOUR. I HAVE SEEN COMBAT
COUNTY AND I HAVE A- EXCELLENT.
NINE ONE. JENNIFER GARNER
OPPOSED. INEX OVER EIGHTY THREE.
AFTER PROJECT RUNNING AYE
OPPOSED. AND THEN WE GOT ONE A
ONE. TODAY THE BALL UP WITH
JUSTICE FOR ALL AYE OPPOSED. BUT
IN LINE EIGHT. GABRIELLE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WE FELT. ONE SEVENTEEN.
ROSE SAN DIEGO AND I OPPOSE.
EXPLAIN. SIXTY FIVE. HELLO AGAIN
YEAH KOBE IN WITH A VERY CURRENT
IN OPPOSITE. I AM CURRENTLY NOT
FURTHER IF YOU. AND AGAIN JUST A
REMINDER FOR FOLKS WHEN YOU. ON
MEET YOU WHEN YOU GO TO TESTIFY
IF YOU CAN MUTE THE DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING US ON WE WILL
GET LESS FEEDBACK AT THAT TIME
AND THEN YOU CAN GO BACK AND
TURN ON SUGGEST. IT WOULD MAKE
YOU IT WOULD MAKE US HERE YOU
BETTER IF YOU MUTED YOUR DEVICE
THAT YOU'RE WATCHING US ON ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FIFTY SIX.
AND WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN FIFTY SIX WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO OUR
NEXT ITEM WHICH IS S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR- BURKE ON
STATE TRANSIT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE
AUTHORS WAVE PRESENTATION WE
WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC TESTIMONY
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX.
THE SUPPORT SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY NINE
IS THE HEAD. ACTUALLY THE LINE
ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY TWO YEAR OPEN. HELLO. ONE THIRTY TWO. HELLO ONE
THIRTY TWO SOUNDS LIKE A SONG.
HANDGUN NO RESPONSE TO THE LACK
. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSED SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
THERE'S NOBODY OPPOSED MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO COULD OPPOSE. TANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN NINETY SIX
I HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
NINE EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG ON CLIMATE CHANGE
PREPAREDNESS AND RESILIENCY AND
JOBS FOR COMMUNITIES IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT. RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND
THERE'S NOBODY RUSSIAN THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
EIGHT NINE. HE'S PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SUPPORT SB NINE EIGHT NINE.
COMMENTING Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF NINE
EIGHTY NINE COME ON A. THREE
LATCH. IN SUPPORT AND FERRIS ME
IN OFF AND BIG OPPOSITION OF THE
SPELL BECAUSE CLIMATE IS NOT
RACIST THANK YOU. THE FIRST. HI
MY NAME IS SERRA OF MAJOR
CORDOVA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PLEASE DIALS THEY WOULD DO IS ON
YOUTUBE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RIGHT FOR MINOR. TRANSACTION
ACCOUNTING I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHANTAJE WIDE SUPPORT TO COME
EARLY AT THAT CORNER SPOT RIGHT
THERE IN FRONT. ALL RIGHT ANYONE
ELSE NO OPPOSITION MODERATOR
ANYBODY ELSE SUPPOSED TO NINE
EIGHTY NINE ON THE PHONE LINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. AND CLEAN UP WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE HERE WILL GO THROUGH ONE
NINETEEN. JENNIFER CORNER A
PUBLIC. FOR THE NEXT LITTLE LINE
EIGHTY THREE. YOUR LINE ONE OH
ONE. CAPABLE OF JUSTICE FOR ALL
I OPPOSE. CURRENTLY NO FURTHER
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NINETY NINE
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE EIGHTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN IS A NON CONTROVERSIAL
BILL BY SENATOR HERTZBERG ON
FIGHT YOU GUYS ARE ALL SUPPOSED
TO LAUGH WHEN I SAID THAT. I
JOKE DIDN'T GO OVER NOT FROM YOU
TO- SB THIRTY TWENTY SEVEN IS ON
FIRE ARM PRIVATE RIGHTS OF
ACTION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. AND THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION I'M ALSO A JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS AS WELL AND WE'LL
OPEN UP PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN EMAIL AND RUSHED TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. CURRENTLY
NINE Q. ALL RIGHT WELCOME TOP
POSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN COME ON IN LINE AS
- JOHN SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHALL
NOT BE INFRINGED OPPOSE. YANO IS
GONNA OFFERS A SWINGING A
TRAINER WITH PLASTER COUNTY
REPRESENTING JAMES. AND- THIS IS
A CANCER SECOND RIGHT SO MORE
STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. HI MY NAME IS SERRA FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. RACHEL CONSTITUTION GATE
PRESCHOOL TEACHER OPPOSE THANK
YOU. FIRST WAGNER STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA STRONG OPPOSE. WHO IS
CHAU TODAY WAS RELEASED ON YOU
TO AND OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
CHAU NOT BE AND- ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE DIRECTORS
TIME TO OPPOSE. WE'LL GO FIRST
ALIGNED. FIFTY NINE. MY NAME IS
WAY THE FEES COMMISSION AS A
SECOND AMENDMENT BILL- THANK YOU
OUR. NEXT SINGLE LINE FIFTY
SEVEN. NFL NUMBER OF FANDOM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AYE OPPOSED TO
FILL. IN NEXT LINE EIGHTEEN.
GABRIELLE INGRAM THE SECOND
AMENDMENT SHALL NOT BE INFRINGED
WE OPPOSE. AND LAND LINE. ONE
NINETEEN. JENNIFER GARNER AS
OPPOSED. IN ONE A ONE A ONE.
FAVORABLE LOG OPPOSE. IN LINE
EIGHTY THREE. I WENT ABOUT THE
FACT THAT MONEY REALLY REALLY
REALLY OPPOSE. AND LINE SIXTY
FIVE. LARRY HOGAN HIM STRONG
SUPPORT THE SECOND AMENDMENT AND
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AND
LINE ONE SEVENTEEN. BERMAN SAID
THE ECHO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
SELF. LINE ONE THIRTY ONE. YES
NATALIE HOLDEN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND AYE OPPOSED TO STEP. AND
LINE. ONE THIRTY TWO. WILLIAM
LASSEN COUNTY I'LL POST THE
VIDEO THANK YOU. AND ONE MORE
HERE GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT.
I WOULD GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
FOUR. CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED
MEDICAL PURITY. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN NO
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN MOVED TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG ON
ACQUISITION OF GOODS AND
SERVICES ALTERNATIVE CONTRACTING
PROCEDURES IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVE
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A COUPLE
FOLKS. YOUR SURE MEMBERS MIKE
MONEY GOING TO BE AT THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. STEPHANIE
HANS LANDSCAPE WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES AND I HIGHLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW THE GUY WHO'S BEHIND.
FIVE W. TO CHANNEL. I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW ME BETTER
THAN THAT ROBERT SMITH- OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX BY.
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE NO ONE ELSE HERE MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO. PRESS ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO.
CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO IS ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
TWENTY TO SEE NOW IN RUSSIA THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. I AM
CURRENTLY LEARNING QUEUE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUTOBJECTION
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO WILL MOVE TO
SUSPEND MOVING ON SB TEN
THIRTEEN BY PRO TEM ATKINS ON
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
PRO TEMAS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TEN THIRTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SUPPORT SB CAN THIRTEEN
. REFER DOCTORS. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
TEN THIRTEEN THERE'S NO RUSH TO
THE MICROPHONES WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE ANYBODY OPPOSED TO
TEN THIRTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO AUTO POST YOU CAN THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU HAVING TAKEN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN
THIRTEEN WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE SB TEN SEVENTEEN
BY SENATOR EGGMAN ON LEASES
TERMINATION OF TENANCY. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. AND
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN SUPPORT
MODERATORS ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE NINE TO TEN SEVENTEEN
. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO SUPPORT.
FOR MORE THAN. ONE ZERO GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT AT ONE FIFTEEN PM. AND WE CAN OPEN LINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. I WOULD GO OVER ON
BEHALF OF THE CULTURE RESPONSES
MEDICARE NETWORK SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR. KERLIN AND FURTHER IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OUT SB TEN SEVENTEEN.
NOBODY COMING IN THE MICROPHONE
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINE HALF
OPPOSITION TEN SEVENTEEN. HE'S
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
GIVE ME A MOMENT HERE GOT ONE IN
Q.
AND WE CAN OPEN LINE TWENTY NINE. YES- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TWENTY GREASY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU KNOW BUT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU. NEXT
HEADLINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA-
WE'RE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. INCREMENTAL
FURTHER A- THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB TEN SEVENTEEN WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN
SEVENTEEN WE'RE GOING TO SUSPEND
THE ON S. B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR EGGMAN INVOLUNTARY
COMMITMENT INTENSIVE TREATMENT
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WHERE IT ALL HAPPENS.
THERE'S NOBODY RUSSIAN IN THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN. TO
SUPPORT SB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I THOUGHT THE IMAM HERE
WE'VE GOT LINE OF ONE THIRTY.
HELLO ALISON MUNRO IT FAMILIES
ADVOCATING FOR THE SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. IN MEXICO
GOT WIND ONE THIRTY THREE. YEAH. AND THEN FOR THEIR QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN. YOUR POST PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CAN GO TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT.
AFTERNOON MISTER SHARON MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AN
OPPOSITION. AND CURRENTLY MAN
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN WITHOUT ANY
QUESTIONS OF SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
MOVING S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE BY SENATOR EGGMAN ON
DISCRIMINATION HOUSING CREDIT
HISTORY OF PERSONS RECEIVING
HOUSING SUBSIDIES. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAVE PRESENTATION AND WE WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY AT TE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
THIRTY FIVE. THE SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO- OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY UP FOR YOU COMING UP.
COME ON UP. SHE ALLEGED PLASTER
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES RALLY
RUNNING FOR US SENATE- I'M IN
OPPOSITION LESS- AMENDMENTS I
THINK THAT THERE'S SOME LANGUAGE
IN HAND THAT NEEDS TO BE AMENDED
SO THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEAN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY- I OPPOSE
ARGUE WITH HER WE SHOULD BE
IMMINENT. JULIA STILES I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS SERRA FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND I OPPOSE. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATE ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSED. YOU
CAN GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE IS GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLEAN GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOU KNOW BOTH THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. AND WE GOT A
LINE FIFTY I'M SORRY EIGHTY
THREE IS GO AHEAD. LINDA PARKER
FUNNY AYE OPPOSED. IN CURRENTLY
NON FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE A MOVE TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN CENTER EGGMAN ON MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES GRAVY GRAVELY
DISABLED IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. FOR SUPPORT THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN SEEING NO ONE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE WITHOUT
OPPOSITION FOR FOURTEEN ACTUALLY
WILL GO TO ONLINE WHEN YOU
SUPPORT I'M ACTUALLY SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT COME ON UP. 30% OF THEIR
OPPOSITION ALONG- CLUSTER COUNTY
MONMOUTH. IN AMERICA INSTRUCTS
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE I A CHILD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN. DISORDER
UNDERSTOOD AND DISORDERS SO WE
NEED TO TAKE CARE ARE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH. OKAY AND THEN THE
CHILDREN OF THAT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE CAN OPEN A LOT. ONE
OUT- NOBODY AT THE TIME YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN SINGAPORE COME
ON UP. CHURN MEMBERS MATTHEW
GALLAGHER COWBOYS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
OPPOSITION. THAT'S ONE ZERO. YOU
CAN OPEN LINE ONE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY YEAR. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT YOU STILL I
DIDN'T GET CALLED AT THE RIGHT
TIME IT WILL SAVE THE LIVES OF
HUNDREDS OF HOMELESS THANK YOU
WE WILL DIAGNOSE. PEOPLE THANK
YOU. NEXT SOBRE LINE FIFTY EIGHT
WERE ACTUALLY ON OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN. HI MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND
CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
AND SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO
SB TEN TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
FURTADO ON WEALTH HEALTH ONE
HEALTH PROGRAMS DO NOT A
DISEASES I'VE BEEN WAITING ALL
DAY TO SAY THE WORDS DO NOT ACT-
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
RIGHT HERE ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE.
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN TWENTY NINE
. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT. SB. TEN TWENTY NINE. IT
CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
TO TEN TWENTY NINE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO TEN TWENTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. YOU CAN GO
ONLINE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHEN THE FEDERAL PARTY
AYE OPPOSED. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN TO COURT IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION TEN TWENTY NINE WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
TWELVE NINETEEN ALSO BY SENATOR
FURTADO A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
WATER LAWS AND AGENCIES IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE.
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
NINETEEN. PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT SB TWELVE NINETY.
CURRENTLY MANICURES ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
TO TWELVE NINETEEN MODERATOR I
TO ME THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM SO MODERATOR ANYONE OPPOSED
TO TWELVE NINETEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. HE
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF TWELVE NINETEEN WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TWELVE NINETEEN WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE MODERATOR GO TO S. B.
TEN THIRTY THREE BY DOCTOR PAN
ON HEALTH CARE COVERAGE THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE GOOD
DOCTOR'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF TEN THIRTY THREE
YEARS NOBODY RUSSIAN IN THE
MICROPHONE IT'S SUPPORT
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. SUPPORT OF A TEN
THIRTY THREE. PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT. B. TEN THIRTY THREE.
THE LINE ONE EIGHTEEN TO GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING NICOLE
BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. X. GO TO LINE. THERE
ARE LIKE ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT TWENTY EIGHT YEAR
OPEN. I THINK I'LL GREG ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU CURRENTLY
NINE FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB TEN THIRTY THREE SEEN
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT BOOK. UP
FOR YOU COME ON UP. HOLD ON A
MODERATE WE HAVE. HIGH STREET
WASHED PLASTER COUNTY MS.
STRONGLY OPPOSED OCCUPATION. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY
NINETY TWO ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
THIRTY THREE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS SO WE WILL PUT THAT ON
THE SUSPENSE FIVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION BILLION SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE AND COVERT NINETEEN
TESTING N SCHOOLS IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE GOOD
DOCTOR'S WAY PRESENTATION WE DO
HAVE ONE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
BUT WE'RE GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW
FOR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. C. NOBODY COME TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. AND FOR SUPPORT
FOR SB FOURTEEN SEVEN NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HELP LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN. I WAS OPPOSED TO THE LAST BILL
BACKGROUNDS OKAY. IN MEXICO LINE
EIGHTY THREE. F. I WOULD
PROPOSAL NO AXIAL AND THIS BILL
RIGHT I THANK MY NUMBER NEVER
THANK YOU MAY HAVE FACTOR COUNTY
. THE NEXT THE LINE. ONE FORTY
ONE. CONTRA COSTA FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE ALL RIGHT WE'RE ON
WE'RE ON SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE SERVE YOU THERE FOR
OPPOSITION JUST. STAY PUT WE'RE
GOING TO FINISH UP WITH WORK
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE. CHARLIE
NINE NINE Q. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
ONE LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
DR JONATHAN SACRISTAN FROM
REOPEN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HE'S
ON THE PHONE LINE AND JONATHAN
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
JONATHAN JACKSON FOUNDER OF REAL
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS WE HAVE SEEN WHAT HAS
WORKED AND WAS NOT WORK TO KEEP
OUR SCHOOLS OPEN. EACH WITH
THEIR OWN COST ONE OF THESE
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN SEVENTY
PROGRAMS BUT IT HAS BEEN SHOWN
THEIR COSTS ARE SIMPLY NOT WORTH
IT ANY AMOUNT OF MONEY SPENT ON
THEM CAN BE MUCH BETTER USED IN
OTHER AREAS TO MAKE UP FOR
MASSIVE LEARNING LIST. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAVE AN INDEFINITE
TESTING PROGRAM IN LINE WITH
GUIDANCE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FAVORITE REQUIREMENT THAT EVEN
CDPH DOESN'T PLACE ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THE REASON YOU COULD
DOESN'T WORK. THEIR OWN TESTING
TO BE FOLLOWED. IS BECAUSE ALL
SCHOOLS FOLLOWED HAS WRITTEN
TODAY IF WE REQUIRE SCHOOLS.
APPROXIMATELY HALF THE STUDENT
POPULATION REGULARLY. AT A COST
OF ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR TO THREE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR THE
TEST HELLO. AND AS WE'VE SEEN
FROM THE PAGE FREQUENTLY UPDATES
OR SCHOOL. THESE CANGES COULD
REQUIRE SCHOOLS RAMP UP TESTING
WITHOUT ANY NOTICE AND AN UNTOLD
COSTS. THE COULD ALLOW SCHOOLS
REDUCE TESTING PER SCHOOL WOULD
HAVE ALREADY INCURRED THE COST
AND NOT EASILY BE ABLE TO RAMP
DOWN. EITHER WAY FOLKS KNOWS ARE
COSTLY TO SCHOOL DISTRICT
UNCERTAINTY FROM SOME STATEMENT
IT'S OFTEN ARE. I THINK A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THE TESTING PROGRAM
NOT THE FOLLOW IS L. A. U. S.
D.'S. WHICH IS THE DIRECTION THE
BILL'S AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA. ONLY A
FEW TEST EVERY STUDENT AND STAFF
WEEKLY THEIR NATIONAL TESTING
PROGRAM BUDGET WAS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION. NOW THAT THE
SCHOOL YEAR'S ALMOST OVER IT IS
ESTIMATED TO COST FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION NEARLY FOUR TIMES
THE INITIAL BUDGET. IF THEY'RE
SAME PROGRAMS APPLY STATEWIDE
WHICH USUALLY TOPIC EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS THIS IS WELL
ABOVE THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
THE BILL'S AUTHOR. IS ASKING
FOR. THE BILL'S ALSO OFFER ALSO
TARGETED. THAT HE CONDUCTED IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
SCHOOLS WHICH IS SIMILAR TO
ELLIE IS DETECTING PLANETS IN
THESE PROGRAMS IT COSTS OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
IDENTIFY A SINGLE POSITIVE TEST
MOST OF WHICH COULD HAVE EASILY
BEEN IDENTIFIED MUCH LESS COSTLY
MEASURES. THESE ARE JUST THE
COST OF THE TEST ALONE THE BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE EACH OF
CALIFORNIA'S ONE THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. HIGHER MINIMUM OF ONE
TO TWO ADDITIONAL STAFF. BUT
THIS LIKELY WOULD BE EXCEEDED TO
KEEP UP WITH THE CP JUST TESTING
THE RAMS ON TOP OF THIS THE BILL
ANALYSIS ESTIMATES ESTIMATES
THAT ONE A ONE TIME COST TO
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS. OF
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
LASTLY THIS BILL WOULD HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON ATTENDANCE
THUS IPACTING TDA FUNDING GOING
BACK TO L. A. U. S. T. THEIR
WEEKLY TESTING ACCORDING PROGRAM
LED TO THEM HAVING ONE OF THE
WORST. CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM RATES
IN CALIFORNIA WITH ALMOST HALF
OF ALL STUDENTS BEING
CHRONICALLY ABSENT SCHOOL
YEAR WHICH IS ABOUT DOUBLE THE
STATE AVERAGE. THE LOWER
DEFINITE ABOUT WASHING EIGHTY
FUNDING TO L. A. U. S. B. IS
EIGHTY MILLION. WITH ALL OF THE
TESTING COST. THERE WAS NO
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES
ONLY WORSE FINANCIAL OUTCOMES
AND A NEGATIVE IMPACT A
STUDENT'S EDUCATION. I ASKED THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE TO THE
BILL SB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE THE
BILL THAT. WOULD IMPLEMENT A
COSTLY CAN DEFINITELY MANY
PROGRAM. AND INSTEAD IS A THE
FUNDING IT. PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
BENEFIT CAL. STATE THANK. THANK
YOU. TO MINUTES AND FIFTY ONCE.
ALL RIGHT COME ON UP. RACHEL I.
GAVE L. A. COUNTY REFUGE AN
OPPOSITE. FOR THE TRAILER LAUNCH
SPEAKING OF TWO ZERO RUNNING FOR
SENATE. CAN GET A LEASE TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK. WE WILL NOT
YEAH TEN YOU CAN SIGN UP WE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE TO WITNESS YET
YOU GET IT WAS A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES AND USED TO MINUTES AND
SECONDS YOU CAN HAS A TEN SO.
OKAY SO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
REITERATE SOMETHING FROM CHD YOU
KNOW PEOPLE ARE VERY- WITH
CHILDREN'S HEALTH DEFENSE- SO
WITH WITH THAT SAID THE- COVERED
HAS REACHED THE AT. ENDEMIC
THEIR FAIR SCHOOL SHOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO ALLOCATE RESOURCES.
TO OPERATE SCOPE IN NINETEEN
TESTING CLINICS ENGAGE IN.
CONTACT RECENT SCHOOL SHOULD BE.
SHOULD INSTEAD BE SUPPORTING AND
THEIR CORE MISSION OF EDUCATING
OUR THINGS CHILDREN. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- SHE GAVE YOU
GIVE ME THE TIME OKAY BUT WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND. OKAY
THANK THANK YOU. HI IF EVERYONE
ELSE COULD JUST BE NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION THAT
WOULD BE CORRECT. HI MY NAME IS
SERRA FROM RANCHO CORDOVA FORMER
PRESCHOOL TEACHER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. JOANIE GRIFFIN I WISH
I HAD AN ORGANIZATION THAT
BECAUSE I'M JUST A PARENT I HAVE
NO UNION AND I HAVE NO LABOR
ORGANIZATION TO FIGHT AGAINST
THIS FOR ME. SO I OPPOSE THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF MY THREE KIDS
THANKS. MY MOM WAS JUST CARE AND
SHE WAS PRETTY COOL. COURTNEY
PETERSON A STANISLAUS COUNTY OF
TAKE A STANCE IN A WE ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. JUST GO ABNER
CURRENTS TEACHER PLACED ON
UNPAID LEAVE BECAUSE OF
DISCRIMINATORY TESTING- OPPOSE.
LUCILE TODAY WAS RELEASED ON YOU
TUBE I OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
AGAIN WE DO NOT CO PARENT WITH
GOVERNMENT. JAMES FRY
SACRAMENTO- I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. SHANTHAKUMARAN COUNTY
I OPPOSE THIS DESTRUCTIVE BILL.
ALL RIGHT MODERATE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE ELSE
SUPPOSED SB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. THE FIRST WONDERFUL POSE.
AND GO TO LINE ONE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS CAROL
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF BRAVE
PARENTS TURN ORANGE COUNTY AND
MYSELF WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THE
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY REAL IN GRAHAM-
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND WE HAVE TO
VOTE NO ON THE CELL. ADELINE ONE
FORTY NINE. NO I AM A PUBLIC
WELL HE AND A MOTHER IF KNOW AND
I OPPOSE. THE LION SEVENTY NINE.
BRAD ANDERSON I'M IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND ONE
FORTY ONE. OUR MOTION PRIOR
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA FREEDOM
KEEPERS I OPPOSE THE STILL. AND
WHY NO ONE. WHERE ARE THE
MEMBERS OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD WORKERS LOCAL
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL
EIGHTEEN AYE OPPOSED. NINETY
FOUR. KATHLEEN THOMAS KERN
COUNTY. LINE ONE THIRTY SIX.
AFTERNOON I'M CHERYL MCEWEN
HARPER ON BEHALF OF THE THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE PEOPLE'S MOVEMENT
OF CALIFORNIA WE ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. FIFTY ONE. HI THE
FOURTEENTH I MEAN I BY ANY
CHANCE IT IS. OKAY MY NAME IS
VERONICA AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR.
YEAH NINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE MY NAME IS
HEATHER HUMANISM A MOTHER AND AN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR OF ONE
FROM SENATOR WOOD COUNTY
DISTRICT OF MY SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS ALREADY GOING TO CLOSE YOUR
BROWSER DOES TALK WHEN YOU SAY
YOU'RE- BUT YEAH. YEAH TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE- OKAY SO YOU. SIXTY
EIGHT. PRINT INVOLVED A PERSON
FROM A ADVOCATE BROWN HAVE TOLD
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS TO WE ASK YOU
TO APPROACH. LINE SIXTY NINE. HI
MY NAME IS ERICA AND FROM HOME
COUNTY I HAVE THE FELL. LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE. HI DEBRA RADIO
INVOLVEMENT HERE WITHOUT FREEDOM
KEEPERS OPPOSITION. LINE ONE
NIGHT. JENNIFER CORNER CLOSE.
THANK. SIXTY FIVE. REPRESENTING
PARENTS AGAINST GOVERNMENT
INVASIVENESS THIS IS TERRY OF
KOBE AND WE OPPOSE BILL SB ONE
FOUR SEVEN NINE THANK YOU SIR.
LINE ONE FORTY. YES THIS IS
MONIQUE WHAT WOULD YOUR PARENTS
FOR CHOICE AND L. A. COUNTY AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LINE ONE SEVENTEEN. HI I'M ROSE
FROM SAN DIEGO I AM A MOTHER OF
THREE AND A PRESCHOOL TEACHER
AND I OPPOSE THAT. LINE ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. AND TO MAKE A
PROFIT FROM STOP THE FEAR WE
OPPOSE. LINE EIGHTY THREE. MY
FOR A FACTOR CONNIE I OPPOSE.
LINE. FIFTY SEVEN. NFL MEMBER OF
FACT STAND UP SACRAMENTO COUNTY
CAN I OPPOSE. NINE ONE FIFTY
THREE. KATHY WHITE MAN WHICH
PROVIDES THE NOW MATT AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. BY. ONE FIFTY
FOUR. COOPER LOS ROSE. HI MY
NAME IS RAVI A CALL AYE OPPOSED. TO FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE. ONE
FORTY FIVE. I THOUGHT THE
FEELING A ROYAL. GRANDMOTHER
GREAT GRANDMOTHER NUMBER YOU
DON'T COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. WHEN. THIRTY TWO. WILLIAMS
ON BEHALF OF ERIC PROTECTION OF
THE EDUCATIONAL RIGHT TO KEEP
AND ALSO SPEAKING AT THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES- WE OPPOSE
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
FOLLOWING A JOB ABOUT THAT- I
WORK AT BEAVER INTERVENTIONIST
AGENDA DISABILITIES WHAT THE L.
UFT L. UFT CONDITION- URGE
ARTICLE SB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY.
ONE FORTY TWO. HI MY NAME IS THE
AMBER GALLAGHER AND I OPPOSE AT
THE FOURTEENTH. ONE THIRTY
THREE. HI MY NAME IS LAURIE
SKINNER FROM CINEMA CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING MYSELF MY CHILDREN
AND THOSE WHO TAKE THE CALL
TODAY INCLUDING STATE ARSENAL
MCCARRON SAVE OUR SCHOOLS WE'RE
CALLING TO OPPOSE THIS
TYRANNICAL BILL PLEASE STOP
PLEASE DON'T GO. THANK YOU.
EIGHTY NINE. A LOT OF PEOPLE
CAN'T FIGURE OUT THE PHONES
TRYING TO THURMOND AND- ONE
FIFTY. HAPPY HOUR DEMOCRATS
PSYCH AND SINAN LABRECQUE MYSELF
AT THE TRAUMA PSYCHOLOGIST FOR
STUDENTS AND FOR PARENT PLEASE
PLEASE PLEASE VOTE NOW THAT THE
SOMEONE NECESSARY RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY EIGHT. HI
MY NAME IS GLORIA I'M CALLING
FROM WORK PULLING OF PARENTS FOR
CHOICE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO FILL THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
ONE. HI DIANE RETRY FROM CINEMA
COUNTY AT THE WESTON MARTIN I'M
A GRANDMOTHER QB TERRY TEACHER
PLEASE OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE FOURTEEN FROM
VOTING THANK YOU FOR MONTHS. ONE
SIXTY ONE. KELLY CALIFORNIA
FOUNDER OF LEGISLATORS AND BILE
BACK YOUR KIDS WE HAVE HOPE
YOU'RE ALL GOING TO HOW. ONE OF
FORTY SEVEN. HI THERE MY NAME IS
LESLIE I'M APPEARING AND I'M
CALLING FROM CINEMA COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE.
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY FOUR. HELLO
MY NAME IS MICHELLE CALL AND I
IN THE BACK OF A VACCINE INJURED
CHILD AND I AM CALLING BECAUSE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO SENATOR PAN
OFFICE ANY DAY ANYMORE THANK YOU
THANKS HER WHEN YOU THINK.
TWENTY TWENTY THIRD YEAH. HI
THIS IS RENEE NELSON I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
. ONE SIXTY. OKAY PRACTICE I'M A
PARENT FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
AM ASKING YOU TO OPPOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FIFTY FIVE. HI
SALLY LAWCENTER. COUNTY PROGRAM
THE FINALITY OF THE FIFTY SIX
KINDERGARTNER I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
JAPANESE BAKERY I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE I CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PAKISTAN'S DENNIS BOB
I'M LOOKING COUNTY LIBERTY
COALITION AND NURSES FOR MEDICAL
FREEDOM AND WE OPPOSE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. ONE
SIXTY THREE. HELLO YOUR THEIR-
YEAH I'M A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
OF FOURTEEN YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE SIXTY
FOUR. WHEN SIXTY FOUR YEAR LINE. AND WITH RESPONSE CARE ACT
MEANT FURTHER INTO. THAT WAS
LAST MONTH. WE THE PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINETEEN OF QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB FIFTEEN HUNDRED. ON
HEALTH. WISH ME TO HELP BILL
IT'S ON BIOLOGICS IT IS A
COMMITTEE BILL THERE'S NO
PRESENTATION THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTEEN HUNDRED. NOBODY HERE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ME JUST A MOMENT
HERE. THANK YOU AT THE TIME OF
AB ONE PEOPLE WILL.
HOLD A MOMENT HERE.
GET OFF THE LINE ONE FORTY THREE
SO I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
SHARE TYLER ARE YOU LEARN THE
ACT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND FOR
THE REST OF TIME- RIGHT WE WILL
COME BACK TO OPPOSITION OF SP
FIFTEEN HUNDRED. THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED. PLEASE PRESS
ONE DIRECTORS TIME.
I WANT YOU HERE GIVE ME JUST A
MOMENT TO GET THEIR NUMBER HERE.
THE OPEN LINE ONE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT HELLO. YES
WE CAN. YES HELLO THIS IS
CRITICS FROM PROTECTION OF
EDUCATION OF THE KIDS AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND AYE
OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
THANK YOU. ONE NINETEEN.
JENNIFER CORBETT OPPOSED. IN
THEM FURTHER AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SP FIFTEEN HUNDRED
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL WILL
GO TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON TO OUR
NEXT BILL WHICH IS. S. B. TEN
SEVENTY THREE BY CENTER GROVE.
ON PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTIONS FOR
DISABLED VETERANS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC IS A SUSPENSE KENNEDY
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION OPEN OF
THE PUBLI TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB TEN
SEVENTY THREE. WORK IS PRESS ONE
ZERO NINE WILL COME BACK TO WORK
. AND WE ARE LINE. ONE SEVENTY.
WHAT. ONE ONE SEVENTY ONE YEAR
OPEN. ARE YOU OVER EIGHTEEN HOW
GABRIELLE INTERESSANTER JANET
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. IN ORDER LINE. FIFTY
SEVEN. THAT NUMBER OF FAN
BARBARA COUNTY FROM THE SUPPORT
. LINE NINETY FOUR. KATHLEEN
THOMAS THE COURT. I'M. ONE
SEVENTY SIX. ONE SEVENTY SIX
RUNS OPEN. WE'RE GONNA LINE
SIXTY FIVE. LARRY COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SEVENTEEN. BROGAN SAN DIEGO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT. LINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. ANYTHING I DO LIKE
THE FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGEL
PRESIDENT A LOT OF MONEY LIBERTY
COALITION IS STRONG SUPPORT. AND
LINE. ONE FIFTY ONE. I WON FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MAY BE
NEEDED FIVE DIARY RIGHT I AM-
SUPPORT FOR THAT THE ELDERLY
THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY ONE.
HI YES MA'AM IN OAKLAND AND I
SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY NINE- WE
LOVE CENTER. ARE YOU NINE ONE
FORTY ONE. FILE IN SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT HERE. RIGHT LINE. ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT. YES HE SAID
BRENNAN FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ONE
NINETEEN. JENNIFER GARNER
SUPPORT. AND FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A COUPLE
SUPPORTERS IN THIS ROOM ALL
RIGHT COME ON UP. A WHOLE BUNCH
CHIEF OUR- THREE GATES ORANGE
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LEWISTOWN'S THEY WOULD DO IS I
NEED TO BUY SUPPORT SB TEN
SEVENTY THREE WAS A POOR OTHER
AND- STRATOLAUNCH. IN BEHALF OF
JAMES P. BRADLEY RUNNING FOR US
SENATE. WERE A STRONG SUPPORT AS
AS OF THIS BILL S. B. I'M SORRY
S. N. SEVENTY THREE. TEN SEVENTY
THREE S. MY GRANDFATHER WAS A
WORLD WAR TWO VETERANS SO WE
SHOULD BE TAKING CARE OF THEM
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS SERRA
FROM RANCHO CORDOVA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THAT'S
CORRECT- STOCKTON CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. ON SECOND ACCOUNTING I
SUPPORT THIS BILL MY FATHER'S A
VETERAN SO WE DEFINITELY TO BE
SUPPORTER OF THAT'S- ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT ESTARÁ
POSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSE NO MODERATORS ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
TEN SEVENTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME OF YOUR
CLOTHES. IF CURRENTLY THE OLD
PARTY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TEN SEVENTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON THE SENATOR
GONZALEZ SB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN ON
VEHICLE CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
WILL TAKE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MONTEREY WENT ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. HE'S PRESS ONE
THERE TO SUPPORT. AND. EIGHTY
SEVEN. CURRENTLY NO PARTY THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATEOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSEDTO TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. YES PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TWO. POST AT. EIGHTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU ARE RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN MOVES TO
SUSPENSE SB TWELVE THIRTY THREE
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ ON
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
UNSERVED OR UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. WILL THE DOCTORS
WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CAN IT WILL OPEN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE THIRTY THREE. THE FIRST
ONE ZERO REPORT. THANK YOU ABOUT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO TWELVE
THIRTY THREE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE
THIRTY THREE. INTERPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION I HAVE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
TWELVE SEVEN TWELVE THIRTY THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO BIKES
SENATOR GONZALEZ ON AIR
POLLUTION CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME SO.
INCRIMINATING Q. ALL RIGHT WE
GOT OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE MODERATOR ARE
YOU PUNCHED I'M GONNA. HOLD ON
MODERATE. MY NAME IS SARAH FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. JOHN SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. PLEASE DIAL
SEVEN COUNTY AYE OPPOSED BILL
YOU FORGOT TO SAY. THEY REAL
ACTION LASSEN COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE NO OR
ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED. TO
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. PRESS ONE
ZERO SO. WE CAN GO TO LINE
SEVENTEEN IF I HAD. I RODE FROM
SAN DIEGO I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SINGLE LINE. ONE NINETEEN.
JENNIFER CORE TO THE PRO.
CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON S. B. ELEVEN OH FIVE BY
SENATOR HUESO AND SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL EQUITABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
FRIENDLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SENATORS MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE
AT THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT. NO ONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE. FIRST SUPPORT THE
FRESHMAN ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL. WITHOUT QUESTION TO ME
WHAT OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE BATTERIES OR
ANY OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE ZERO
TO OPPOSE. YES ONE ZERO GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT HERE.
CAROLINE. THIRTY OUR MEMBERS
JENNIFER STACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE MEASURE OF THE NUMERATOR
BUYER LETTER. THANK YOU. IN
CURRENTLY KNOWN FOR THEIR QUEUE
. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION NO QUESTIONS THAT
OBJECTION S. B. ELEVEN OH FIVE
ABOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR
HUESO SENATE ROUTE ONE TWENTY
FIVE TOLL PROJECT IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE. PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SUPPORT. I AM CURRENTLY
LEARNING QUEUE ALL RIGHT WHAT
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY
NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
AT THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WHO IS
OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN SIXTY NINE. A
POST SB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE CAN
OPEN LINE ONE SEVENTEENTH- HIGH
ROSE FROM TEN YEARS AGO OPPOSE
HOLD ON ONE TWENTY FIVE. HE
CURRENTLY NINE FURTHERING ECHO
SKILL. WAS THAT THE LAST ONE
THAT WAS OPPOSITION. YEP PORT
THAT'S ONLY MY SECOND MYSELF.
AFTER THREE HOURS ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION NOW
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED I'M
GONNA BLAME MY CASKET FOR
DISTRACTING ALL RIGHT NO
OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN SIXTY NINE.
HI AND AGAIN IT IS ONE ZERO WE
CAN OPEN UP. ONE SEVENTY. I'M
SORRY I THOUGHT I. HEARD THAT
RIGHT- I OPPOSE THE WHOLE TIME
IS THAT WHAT. YOU CAN HEAR WHAT
BILL YOU OPPOSED TO. I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE NUMBER OF IT ABOUT
THE ONE TWENTY FIVE SAN DIEGO
THAT'S THIS ONE SO YOUR POST SB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK. AND THEN FURTHER AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
SIXTY NINE I HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION ELEVEN SIXTY
NINE GOT A SUSPENSE MOVIE AND-
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE BY SENATOR
HUESO ON USED TYRES IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY
AT THE MICROPHONE TO SUPPORT IT
MODERATE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. OF ELEVEN
EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SUPPORT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
ONE. CURRENTLY LEARNING QUEUE
ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO
OPPOSITION ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR ANYONE OPPOSED TO
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
OPPOSE. I CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY ONE WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR WAY SOMEONE ELECTRICITY
STORAGE FACILITIES STANDARDS AND
RECORDS IS TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC PHONE LINE
FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. APART
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HE CURRENTLY MANY CUTE
COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE ROOM OPPOSED
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TWO
POSTS THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR ALAN ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT. THE FIRST ONE THERE TO
SUPPORT. ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT.
NINETY TWO AT THIS TIME WILL
COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF
LEVIN THIRTY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT. NFL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO OPPOSE. IT CURRENTLY NINE Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO
THIS ROOM FOR QUESTIONS SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB TWELVE ALL
FIVE BY CENTER ALLEN ON WATER
RIGHTS. SUPPORT WELL HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION AND IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HAD TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT
OF TWELVE OH FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT. IN ANY
QUEUE AT THIS TIME WILL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO
TWELVE OH FIVE MODERATORS ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE OH FIVE. IF SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. ARE RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF TWELVE OH
FIVE I HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION TWELVE OH FIVE A MOVE
TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON THE
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
ALLEN ON THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IS SUPPORTED
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO. PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY NINE CUTE
ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK WITH
THE SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL
COME BACK HERE TO ANY QUESTIONS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BY SENATOR ALLEN ON BUILDING
STANDARDS CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. HE LIKE
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NOT AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM COME ON UP
MISTER CHAIRMAN PURCELLVILLE FOR
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SHOULD THE BILL COME
OUT OF COMMITTEE WE'RE HOPEFUL
WE CAN WORK ON AND GET IT RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE HERE NO
MORE MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. PRESS ONE ZERO SL
AND I CAN OPEN UP LINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CREE
INCREASE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND CURRENTLY NINE NINE FOUR
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR KABIRU ON ABORTION
SERVICES WE DO HAVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION. WITNESS WILL BUT
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP WITH PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN FORTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT.
CURRENTLY MANY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT WILL COME BACK TO THIS
REFLECTION WE WILL GO TO OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION WHICH IS SUSAN
ON ALL FROM THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE. YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE LINE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MY NAME IS AN ART
ALL I AM I PRESIDENT OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS AT RIGHT I THINK
AMERICA'S FIRST FROM. WE ARE
ASKING ME- OPPOSE. AT. B. I'M-
BY NO CRITICAL PORTION OF BIRTH.
DATE IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL TO
COMMITTEE TO DO REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHT MYERS I FEEL LIKE FORTY
TWO BY A THE CAL BECAUSE-
BECAUSE YEAH WANT HIDING IT. ON
THE MAKING COMMITTEE CORPS CHILD
. IN FEEDING OUR OUR THE COURT
RULED THANK YOU FOR BY ALL THE
CATTLE CON. I FINANCIALLY CHINA
OVER ABORTION CONDITIONING OF
BETTER FRAME TODAY MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS LATER SB ELEVEN TWO
FAVORS I'M FOR OVER TRYING TO
WORK AT ELEVEN FORTY WILL IT HI
WOMEN TO BOOK FREE ABORTION. ST
WEB WHO NAY ERR IN COST SET UP
LIVE REIMBURSED LAW LAKE IN AND
EVEN ARRAY FOR BAY SAID THANK.
ELIGIBILITY TO TRAVEL. ONLY
PREGNANT PEOPLE WHO WISH REPORT
ARE ELIGIBLE TO CONFIRM THE
PREGNANCY BEFORE THE PATIENT
ARRIVES IN CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR
FREE ABORTION. WHAT
RAMIFICATIONS WILL CALIFORNIA
STATE TAXPAYERS SPACE FOR
ENTICING UNDER AGE GIRLS HERE
FROM OTHER STATES TO PERFORM
ABORTIONS YEAH HE LEGAL ADVICE
HELLO. WE ALL SB ELEVEN FORTY
TWO TRAFFIC UNDER AGE MYERS
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT PARENTS
KNOWLEDGE FOR ABORTION
PROCEDURES. AND WHAT IF WOMEN
WHO COME HERE CHANGE THEIR MIND
I WANT TO KEEP THE BABY DO YOU
THINK. WE'LL SIMPLY ABSORB THE
COST OR WILL BE. HELD THESE
WOMEN. EIGHT PROGRAMS PAY FOR
THE SIX. ARE FOR FINING CORP.
FORCING TO CLOSE THEIR EYES AND
SPEND THE LEGS IN THE STORE TO
AVOID THE COST. YEAH THE ONLY BY
PRODUCT TO FACE ONE REPORTER
CHOICE OVER A- WHAT ARE PRINT.
IN NINETY EIGHTY ONE. AND IT
REMAINS. TODAY VERY GOOD REASON
FOR YOU TO VOTE NO ON THE ELEVEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. ALL RIGHT THAT WAS OUR
LEAGUE OPPOSITION WITNESS WILL
COME BACK TO THIS ROOM FOR THOSE
WHO WISHING TO. OFFER MEETING
TESTIMONY ON SB ELEVEN FORTY
TWO. RACHEL GATE PRESCHOOL
TEACHER. PRO CHOICE AND OPPOSE.
WATCH SPEAKING BEHALF OF DREAMS
RUN FOR US AND THIS BILL IS. IT
ALSO VIOLATES- MANY MANY FEDERAL
LAWS SO YES WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SPELL. HI MY NAME IS
SERRA FROM RANCHO CORDOVA I'M
PRO CHOICE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. JULIA STILES TODAY WAS
RELEASED ON YOUTUBE I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. SEAN FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY I OPPOSE THIS BILL. RIGHT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. SEEING NONE SB
ELEVEN FORTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE JUST. IT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE THIRTY ONE
BY SENATOR KABIRU WAS OUR NEXT
BILL. I'M SORRY WOULD INTO THE
PHONE LIKE THAT WAS MY FAULT. I
WAS MAKING MY T. OVER THE PHONE
LINE FOR OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY TWO FIVE MY BAD. IT
IS ONE ZERO WELL FIRST OF ALL I
NINETY FOUR. HI. THE LINE FIFTY
SEVEN. CAN THAT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY CAN I OPPOSED. THE LATE
FIFTY NINE. I WELL I HAD TO
ABORTION I'M A LIFELONG DEMOCRAT
. WHAT THE PEOPLE WANT THANK YOU
. ONE SEVENTEEN. ROAD TEN YEARS
AGO AYE OPPOSED. ONE THIRTY ONE.
ONE THIRTY ONE ONE I'M SORRY
MARY HOLDEN SEMINAL COUNTY AND
AYE OPPOSED. AND. THREE APPLE
INC REMINDED HER THAT FELL. ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN. VETR FROM ORANGE
HI THE CORNER ORANGE AND I
THOUGHT. AND ONE SEVENTY NINE.
MY NAME IS TERRY WILLIAMS FROM
ESCONDIDO CALIFORNIA SENATE
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY TWO. ONE NINETEEN.
JENNIFER FOR ASTRONOMICAL. AND
THEN FURTHER ISSUE AT THIS TIME
. ALL RIGHT I APOLOGIZE FOR
MIXING THINGS UP THERE FOR
SECOND- WE TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION BOTH HERE AND ON THE
PHONE LINE. NONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUICK QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- IT'S IMPORTANT WE
GET THIS RIGHT ADJUSTED SHARES
COMMENT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
I'M FORTY TWO AND- JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT. AS A FATHER TO
DAUGHTER SISTER IT'S IMPORTANT
WE NEED WE NEED TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA. CONTINUE TO BE A PRO
CHOICE- ST STE MY OWN EDITORIAL
PAYMENT. AS CHAIR SO THANK YOU
WITHOUT OBJECTION SPLM FORTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE ON SB
TWELVE THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR
KABIRU CALIFORNIA STANDARD
DIAGNOSTIC VALLEY FEVER. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MOVING TO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATE OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE THIRTY ONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO SO. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION SB TWELVE THIRTY ONE
CAMPERO THERE'S NO ONE HERE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE THIRTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEIR TOP
POLLS. IN NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE THIRTY ONE SINGLE
QUESTION FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE TWELVE
THIRTY ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB ELEVEN SIXTY BY
SENATOR DORADO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION EXEMPTION
FROM NON RESIDENT TUITION THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE NO
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN SIXTY
. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN SIXTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
COMING TO OPPOSE ELEVEN SIXTY
MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO ELEVEN SIXTY. SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NOT AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
SIXTY WITHOUT OBJECTION ELEVEN
SIXTY WILL GOT NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION ELEVEN SIXTY
GOT A SUSPENSE MOVIE IN SB
THIRTEEN OH NINE BY SENATOR
DORADO OUTDOOR ADVERTISING
DISPLAYS EXEMPTIONS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP
AND AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC TESTIMONY
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM TWELVE TWENTY
TWELVE THIS TO ME TWENTY TWENTY.
THERE ANYONE HERE NO MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN OH NINE. THE
FIRST ONE THERE TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN OH NINE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION S. B. THIRTEEN OH
NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSE MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN
OH NINE. INTERPOSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT
HERE.
AND LOOK IT UP ONLINE TWENTY
THREE. FIVE MILLION MY PHONE TO
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING FOR THE
PATIENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTY NINE. IN EARLY AND
FURTHER ISSUE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN OH NINE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIRTEEN WHEN I WAS ON A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB ELEVEN
NINETY NINE BY GENERAL ROTH ON
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE GENERAL'S
WAY PRESENTATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWENTY THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN NINETY NINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. CHLORITE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO ELEVEN NINETY
NINE. AND TO OPPOSE NOW PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. HEY CHRIS NOBODY
A Q. KERR RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
ELEVEN NINETY NINE WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
THREE BY GENERAL ROCK ON PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT. CURRENTLY NOBODY H. Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN THIRTY
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
THIRTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO TWO. VOICE YOUR OPPOSITION
I FOLLOW OKAY NO PROBLEM YES ONE
DAY A LONG MORNING. ONE ZERO IT
IS. AND I THINK YOU'RE FINE ALL
RIGHT WE'LL THAT WAS OPPOSITION
RIGHT ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OUR
COLLEAGUES THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION FOURTEEN
THIRTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR BY GENERAL
ROTH ON THE STATE BOARD OF
CHIRAQ CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING RIGHT HERE
AND IT'S A SUSPENSE KEVIN WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOUR. AND PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT.
JUST A MOMENT HERE GOT ONE WITH
AN OPERATOR.
STILL HOLDING HERE. SORRY WE CAN
OPEN LINES SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY TELLY THREE.
ANALYSTS LIKELY TO CONSULT A Q.
THE SENATE. YES IT AT THIS TIME
HER O'CONNOR OPPOSITION FOR
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATOR
ANYONE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOUR. SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I AM
CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL RIGHT
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION SENIOR
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR WE GOT A
SUSPENSEFUL SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX BY GENERAL ROCK ON EXPERT
FOR RESPIRATORY THERAPY IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE AS WE OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT OF NOT WANTING TO.
BY.
ARE YOU CAN OPEN LINE CAN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR PORTANTINO AND
MEMBERS DISRESPECTING YOU HAVE
WITH THE RECTORY CARE PORT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
COME BACK TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
PROPOSITION. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SHOW YOUR- OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO. I
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPEND SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT BY GENERAL ROTH AND
PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
. SHOW YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CAN GO
TO LINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CARL WANTED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA.
THERAPY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK. AND CURRENTLY NO FURTHER
WILL COME BACK TO THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. HE'S
PRESS ONE ZERO CELL. HE
CURRENTLY NOBODY IN HERE ALL
RIGHT- WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION FOURTEEN
THIRTY ABLE GO TO SUSPENSE SB
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE BY GENERAL
ROTH ON THE PART OF THE CONSUMER
AFFAIRS IS THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE GOT HIS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN FORTY THREE
. PRESS ONE ZERO SL. CURRENTLY
NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATOR ANYONE OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE. THE POST
AT. ONE ZERO. AND NOBODY HERE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION FOURTEEN FORTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TO A BNP COMMITTEE BILL SB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE ON
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS IS THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE CHAIRS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE
. YOUR SUPPORT PACK PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
TO FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATOR
ANYONE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE. ONE ZERO TYPOS. AND
NO BEING TO HAVE TO FIND WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE A
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO VICE
CHAIR BATES SAYS SB TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR ON WATERSHEDS WILD
LIFE HABITAT IT IS FOR COUNTIES
OF ORANGE AND SAN DIEGO IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MY COLLEAGUE
AS WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC. BUT YOU'RE GOOD THIS IS
. SHE SUPPORT WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR THERE'S
NOBODY HERE- WILL GO ON THE
PHONE LINE. THE SUPPORT TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR. THIS PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. NINETY TWO
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE UP
QUITE OPPOSED TO TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR. IF SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND NOT AT THIS TIME WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND
WITHOUT QUESTION AND OBVIOUSLY
WITH THE VICE CHAIRS FULL
SUPPORT THIS BILL SO GO TO
SUSPENSE BUT OUT OF WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING ON TO S.
B. TWELVE FORTY FIVE FROM MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR KAMLAGER ON
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY ABORTION
ACCESS SAFE HAVEN PILOT PROGRAM.
WE DO HAVE ONE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS BUT WILL GO TO PUBLIC
TECH THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION AND IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE FORTY
FIVES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. THESE PRESS ONE ZERO INFO. AND I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT WILL
GO TO OPPOSITION AS I SAID WE
HAVE A LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AGAIN IT SUSAN ARE
NOT ALL FROM RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO MY
NAME IS NOT ALL AS YOU KNOW I
TOLD YOU BEFORE I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGAL AFFAIRS AT
THE RIGHT TO LIFE. WHICH IS
AMERICA'S FIRST PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION WE WERE FOUNDED IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. SB TWELVE FORTY
FIVE WILL EXPAND ABORTION ACCESS
IN L. A. COUNTY. BECAUSE IT IS
ONE SIDED IN THE FUNDING MAKING
NO ACCOMMODATION FOR ACCESS TO
CHILDBIRTH SERVICES HIT LATELY
VIOLATE THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION UNDER COMMITTEE TO
DEFEND REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
VERSUS MYERS. MOREOVER AND FEES
. FORTY FIVE INTENTIONALLY
TARGET CHILDREN OF COLOR FOR
EXTERMINATION. AS BILL ITSELF
STATE. L. A. COUNTY IS HOME 228%
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION.
ALREADY ACCOUNTS FOR MORE THAN
ONE THIRD OF ALL ABORTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. AS THE BILL ITSELF
STATE. MOST ABORTION FACILITY IN
L. A. COUNTY ARE IN LOW INCOME
HIGH MINORITY AREAS. SO THE BILL
ITSELF ADMITS. THAT IT TARGETS
FOR MINORITIES FOR ELIMINATION
THROUGH ABORTION. ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY FOURTEEN THIRTY IN THAT
LOCKER. 75% OF WOMEN WHO HAD
ABORTIONS YOUR WHAT'S MORE
LIKELY TO BE LOW. INCOME FOR
POOR. AND CHAO MARK SANGER
WASN'T IS NEEDED BY THE PREMISES
HE PROMOTED BIRTH. AND A FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE. SAY YOU'RE REFER
TO THEM AND I AS WE THE HUMAN
BEING WHO SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
BORN. SB TWELVE FIVE FOLLOWS HE
JENNY. YELLEN CHILDREN COLOR.
THERE IS NO GREATER THAN THE
POWER OF THE PURSE. WE SHOULD
NEVER MAKE A WOMAN CHOOSE
BETWEEN RENT AND HAVING A- LET
TRIAL. AND A- AND CHILD CARE ON
THE DOCK SERVICES. LOW INCOME
MINORITIES HAVE THE SAME OPTIONS
AS WOMEN OF PRIVILEGE AND WEALTH
TO HAVE THEIR BABIES NOT ABORT
THEM PLEASE VOTE NO ON SB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL COME BACK TO THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO UP. WE DO COME
ON UP. JULIA STILES TODAY WOULD
YOU PLEASE I NEED TO I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB ONE FOUR. ONE TWO
FOUR FIVE I STAYED DOWN BORN
LIVES MATTER AS MUCH AS BORING
LIFE. NO ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR FOR ANY AFTER THE
OPPOSITION TO TWELVE FORTY FIVE
. SO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WELL LANE FIFTY NINE.
I'VE HAD TWO ABORTIONS I'M PRO
CHOICE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
SIX CALIFORNIA YOU. THANKS A
LITTLE LINE EIGHTEEN. HI THIS IS
GABRIELLE AND GRAHAM I DO NOT.
THINK ABOUT NOW. INITIAL. ONE
EIGHTY THREE. THE PROMISE OF.
OPPOSE THANK YOU AND LINE FIFTY
SEVEN. THIS CANNOT FELT I HAVE
HEARD OF. LINE. ONE NINETEEN.
JENNIFER CORNELL OPPOSE. LINE
ONE THIRTY ONE. MIAMI HOPING TO
BUILD COUNTY. NINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE. JERRY WILLIAMS AND I
OPPOSE SB. ONE TWO FOUR FIVE.
NINE. ONE SEVENTEEN. THIS IS
ROSE FROM SAN DIEGO I OPPOSE.
AND LINE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. WE
CAN BE SEVEN. WELL GO TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY FIVE. I THOUGHT THAT
IT I GOT IT ALL EITHER THEY
HADN'T HEARD IT. COME EUREKA
RENDON FROM THE RIGHT POLITELY
IN OPPOSITION AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. AND THEN FOR AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION SB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE THIS CALMER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WASN'T
PLANNING TO SPEAK BUT I GUESS I
WILL I WOULD LIKE YOU TO KNOW
THAT I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL SB TWELVE FORTY FIVE IT'S
NOT ABOUT RACE IT'S ALSO NOT
ABOUT MARGARET SANGER SHE'S DEAD
THIS IS ABOUT WOMEN AND THEM
HAVING THE RIGHT WE HAVING THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE. OUR OWN
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS I AGREE BORN
LIVES ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
WHICH IS WHY I WONDER WHY FOLKS
WHO OPPOSE THIS BILL. SUPPORT
THE CRIMINALIZING OF WOMEN WHO
ARE PREGNANT AND WOMEN WHO HAVE
MISCARRIAGES. THIS IS ABOUT A
WOMAN HAVING THE RIGHT TO MAKE-HER OWN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
DECISIONS SO IF I DON'T TELL YOU
WHAT TO DO WITH YOUR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE RATES
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO TELL ME
WHAT TO DO WITH MINE THAT IS ALL
THIS BILL DOES AND IT DOES IT IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BY CREATING.
A SAFE HAVEN FOR ABORTION ACCESS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISS KAMLAGER FOR YOUR COMMENTS
. WITHOUT YOUR TIME IS OVER NO
ALL RIGHT. SO WE HAVE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WE HAD ONE
COMMENT NO OTHER QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE THE MOVE TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
ALSO BY SENATOR CALM WATER AND
GREENHOUSE GASES MARKET BASED
COMPLIANCE MECHANISMS. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF. THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE. PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. CURRENTLY
MANY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK TO OPPOSITION FOR THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE. AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. HE GOT A
LINE ONE NINETEEN S. AHEAD.
JENNIFER CORNERS OPPOSED. YOU
CAN GO TO ONE SEVENTY. WROTE A
POST. AND FURTHER ASSIST IN-
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB TWELVE FIFTY THREE
BY SENATOR MELENDEZ ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN FLOOD
CONTROL DELTA LEVEES TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
NOBODY HERE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE FIFTY THREE. HELLO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WELCOME THE
OPPOSITION FOR TWELVE FIFTY
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATOR ANYONE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE FIFTY THREE. AND PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO SL. BY THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE FIFTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB TWELVE SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR STERN ENERGY ASSISTANCE
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING EXTREME
HEAT SOUND MITIGATION GRANTS. IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SENATOR
STERN WAY PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
SIXTY ONE. NOBODY'S HERE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. HE'S PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. GIVE ME A MOMENT I'VE
GOT ONE WITH AN OPERATOR. WE CAN
OPEN LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE. HI
RICHARD ACROSS LOS ANGELES CITY
COUNCIL PAUL CORRECT HIS OFFICE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE SIXTY
ONE- TWELVE SIX YEAH WHAT DO YOU
WANT. CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IF
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATE ANYONE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE SIXTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY NOBODY A
QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
TWELVE SIXTY ONE MOVE TO
SUSPENSE SB FOURTEEN OH FOUR BY
SENATOR STERN ON SEQUEL- AND OAK
WOODLANDS IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVE
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF
SUPPORTERS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN OH
FOUR. HE'S PRESS ONE ZERO TWO
SHOWS SUPPORT. AN OPEN UP. ONE
ONE EIGHTY ONE. IT TAKEN THEM
SO- ARE CURRENTLY NOBODY- ALL
RIGHT WELL WHAT OFFICER WE'RE
GOING ON THIS ISSUE GO DOWN.
WHAT THE SAY WHAT IF YOU HAVE
ONE EIGHTY ONE OPEN AFFECT OKAY
GO AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY ONE OF. AB
TRADED FROM LA CITY
COUNCILMEMBER PAUL CORRUPTS
OFFICE AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTINO. FOR ALL RIGHT WE'LL
COME BACK TO THIS REMEMBER
FREDERICK YOU WILL COME BACK
OPPOSITION YEAH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER SILVIO FOR OUR IN DEPTH
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THE BILL HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED AS ONE OF THE FEW
HOUSING KILLERS OF THE YEAR I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS. THAT DOES
RECOGNIZE THERE'S GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANT STATE COST BECAUSE
THIS BILL AND THERE'S A NUMBER
OF OTHER EXISTING PROGRAMS TO
HANDLE THIS ISSUE WOULD JUST
THINK THIS IS A- SOLUTIONS. OF A
PROBLEM SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. ALL RIGHT MODERATE OR
ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED. TO
FOURTEEN OH FOUR. SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. IT CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. ARE I HAVEN'T TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITHOUT
OBJECTION FORTINO FOR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE COLLEAGUES WERE ON OUR
LAST PAGE AND WE HAVE. S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX. FROM SENATOR
STERN ON MENTAL HEALTH CARE IT'S
A SUSPENSE CAN MAKE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC TESTIMONY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. MODERATE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN FORTY SIX.
THESE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN FORTY SIX
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN FORTY
SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I THINK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN FORTY SIX
WITHOUT OBJECTION FROM MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE QUESTIONS THAT
OBJECTION FOURTEEN FORTY SIX
VOTER SUSPENSE MOVING SB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN FROM SENATOR
RUBIO DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT MOBILE
HOME PARK ACT IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANADA AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE SUPPORTING THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
CHARACTERS TIME. CURRENTLY NINE
ISSUE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION AT THIRTEEN OH SEVEN-
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN OH SEVEN ON
THE PHONE LINE. THE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
OVER THE AGE YOU. ALL RIGHT DO
WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF THIRTEEN OH SEVEN AND THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS. MODERATOR LET'S-
ACTUALLY MAKE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN WILL GO TO- SUSPENSE WE
STILL HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL
RIGHT. AND SO. MR JONES SOMEBODY
SHOULD CALL MISTER JONES OKAY
ALL RIGHT MOVING ON S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE. SENATOR
OCHO BOGUE- IT IS PUBLIC
CONTRACTS GOODS AND SERVICES
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IT CURRENTLY NOBODY IN Q.
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN TWENTY
ONE. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN CURRENTLY ALREADY IN QUEUE
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITH THAT THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE BY SENATOR JONES ON
LICENSING BOARDS TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE I SHOULD BE
SUPPORT OF ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE SUPPORTING THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE
OKAY LIKE TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT.
NOBODY HERE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION AT
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATOR
ANYBODY OPPOSED. TO THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. A POST PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NOBODY H. U. S. TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD ON INCARCERATED PERSONS
AND WAGES IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE MY COLLEAGUES WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR ANYONE O THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT. NOBODY AQ ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FROM
POSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. AND IF ONE OF PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
NOBODY TO RECTIFY. ALL RIGHT SO
HE'S ALREADY DONE IT THAT WAS MY
MISTAKE- YES. OKAY SO WE DON'T
NEED DOCTOR JOHNSON ALL RIGHT SO
WE'RE ON OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. NOBODY HEAR ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE. PRESS ONE
ZERO SO. NOBODY H. YOU AT THIS
TIME OUR RIGHTS WERE NO
SUPPORTER NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON
SB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX BY
pCREDIT REPORTING IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE GOOD SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO SHOW SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX ON THE PHONE
LINE. HE'S PRESS ONE ZERO. A
CURLY NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AT THIRTEEN NINETY SIX AND
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT THEY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB FORTINO ONE FROM
SENATOR BRADFORD ON COLLEGE
ATHLETE RACE AND GENDER EQUITY
ACT IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE GOOD SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY
HERE IN SUPPORT MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN A ONE. HE'S PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOBODY IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION A FORTINO ONE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE A POOR
OPPOSED TO FORTINO ONE. AND
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE ONE HERE WITH AN
OFFER TO COUPLE WITH MAPPING-
GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT. I CAN
OPEN LINE ONE THIRTY ONE.
HOAGLAND FAMILY COUNTY MY
APPROACH. MEXICO LINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN. TWENTY SEVEN. HI THIS.
CALIFORNIA. IN LINE. ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT. AND NOT FOR THEIR QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION FORTINO
ONE SINGLE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FORTINO ONE
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR GLAZER ON
FACTUAL INNOCENCE IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
TESTIMONY HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. INTERLINING
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT IS THERE ANYONE HERE NO
MODERATOR ONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
. THIS PRESS ONE ZERO SO.
INCRIMINATING Q. WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE OUR FINAL BILL IS SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY BY SENATOR
GLAZER ON REMOTE ACCESSIBLE VOTE
BY MAIL SYSTEMS IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE ENATOR GLAZERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THE
NOBODY HERE TO SUPPORT MODERATE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. IT CANNOT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO SO. AND I CAN GO TO
LINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. SINGLE LINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND NO RESPONSE
OF FIFTY NINE. NUMBER THREE Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
LET'S CUT OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN AIR
WHAT THEY ARE I'M GONNA. JHOULYS
GILES THEY WILL RELEASED ON YOU
TOO I OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE ANY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY
. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. A LITTLE LINE FIFTY NINE
IF I HAD. WE'VE ARE ALEXION
BELOW ONLY THE RECALL- WE- AND
WE GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTEEN IF I
HAD. ROSENFELD REYES BOTH. ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JENNIFER CORBETT OPPOSED. NINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WSTK
CALLS ON BEHALF OF VERIFIED
VOTING IN OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTY. IN CURRENTLY AND FURTHER
IN Q. FOR DIRECTOR WILL GLUCK
FLIGHT FIFTY SEVEN IF I HAD.
THANK YOU CAN PHELPS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. AND GIVE ME JUST A
MOMENT HERE. NINE ONE THIRTY ONE
YEAR OPEN. MIAMI HOPING AN APPLE. IN AND I WANT TO SPEAK WITH AN
OPERATOR HERE WE'LL GO TO LINE.
ONE FAMILY SEVEN. HI HEATHER
COLLABORATES CLOSELY. ONE EIGHTY
NINE. A GOOD AFTERNOON HAS
BROUGHT OVER THANK YOUNG I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND FURTHER IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SINGLE QUESTIONS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE THAT'S ALL
THE BILLS WE DO HAVE ONE ON
CALL. SB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE.
MISTER CONSULTANT IF YOU WOULD
LIFT THE CALL IN SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIVE. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE ZERO SENATE
DEBATES. RIGHT THE CLAIM OF THE
CLAIM YEAH. SENATE DEBATES EYES
CENTER CON LONGER. THE CALM
WATER HI THE LOTUS SEVEN ZERO
THAT PHYLLIS OUT SEVEN ZERO SO
THAT IS ALL OF OUR BILLS TODAY
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THANK
YOU ALL FOR PARTICIPATING IN THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY- IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
PARTICIPATION AND YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION TODAY WE'VE
CONCLUDED OUR BUSINESS AND SO
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.